Three,
two,
one,
yes.
Dan Carlin.
Where ally,
what's up buddy?
I kick you again.
Always a pleasure.
Bye.
Ooh,
all the time.
You to me are like this guy that's
working on this never ending project
that occasionally you release these
chunks of these never ending projects,
but I look at your podcast has this
great work,
this long.
Never ending like dramatic
interpretation of history.
That's so exciting and interesting.
But when you were talking before the
podcast about podcasting,
but I don't think of what you do as
anything remotely like what I do.
Like he was like,
you do so many podcasts in my cabinet.
There's nothing to it.
You start it,
you start talking and that's it.
You have like preparation and research
and you know when you're doing hardcore
history that's like a great work.
Like you're doing like this thing that's
evergreen,
that's going to be passed down forever
and bit torrent did the fuck out of
Danieli.
Bolelli had a great line to me cause you
know,
he does a history podcast now too and he
started off by doing just a,
a talk.
One of my common sense kind of his,
and he said the difference with the
history one is you actually have to,
it has to make,
it has to make sense when you're done.
I mean the banks,
so that's a huge.
I mean I sit there like forever and I
ended up in my,
my wife's never heard it by the way I,
my kids don't understand why anybody
would want to hear me talk and you know,
so,
but when I come out of the studio and
you know,
like sweat pouring off me and I'm trying
to,
and then we'll look at it and it doesn't
mean you're listening,
you'll hear a mistake and you'll have to
repair the mistake and you know,
when you're just doing a,
when I'm talking on the political
podcast and we make a mistake,
I'll say afterwards on twitter,
all I got that wrong on the history one,
like you said,
it's forever and so you really have to
dot your i's and cross your t's and all
that kind of stuff.
It makes it a lot harder.
Yeah.
When you do in common sense,
you're essentially just sort of ranting
about your thoughts on what's going on
and that's a pretty good description.
Yeah.
When you do those and you release them
and you find out you made an error,
that is a fucking pain in the ass,
right?
I,
I recently blamed one on concussions or
brain damage or something like that.
So yeah,
in reference to Hillary Clinton.
No,
I know.
I said,
uh,
I was talking about that stuff they
throw out of airplanes to jam radars and
I called it flash and of course it's
chaff and all of course 10,000
military people go,
you know,
it's chaffed.
And I go,
of course I know the chaff.
I wouldn't have brought it up.
It's brain damage.
Don't make fun of people who are
injured,
you know.
So,
but on the history show,
you have to go,
okay,
I gotta go recut that.
Refixed it.
I do a lot more editing than I used to.
Yeah.
That's,
um,
yeah,
it's,
you're,
like I said like you have a podcast,
but then you also have this thing,
the heart cast are killing me by the
way.
I'm going to at some point I'm going to
have to just do like one podcast a year,
you know,
I just,
I am the slowest podcaster in the world.
I have one claim to fame number one in
time it takes to get a new show out.
It's not the same.
See,
that's the problem with calling your
thing a podcast.
It's an audio show.
It is at this point.
It evolved into that unintentionally.
But you have a podcast too.
I do getting longer,
longer between Joseph.
Well,
it's got to be like when I listened to
some of your podcasts,
like the one on Martin Luther and what
was the name of that one?
The prophets had to do them.
Yeah,
that one you're like,
I learned about lutherism from you.
Like I didn't,
I didn't know the history.
Right Joe?
Let's.
But I think that's happening with a lot
of people that are like learning about
certain aspects of,
of history from,
from you and from,
from your stuff.
So a lot of responsibility if billy.
So it makes sense that you're spending
as much time on them is what I think
what happens is.
I think originally if you recall that
the shows if you go listen to the old
shows,
they don't sound like the newer ones is
because I thought I was just going to
talk about funky stuff in history and
then people wrote and go,
I don't really know the story.
Can you tell more of the story?
And so you inadvertently start telling
the story and then you go,
wait,
I'm not qualified to tell the story.
And so it just.
Yeah,
it's,
it's an interesting.
It's an interesting.
The way it's evolved and it's also
interesting.
I was,
you know,
I warn people when they go and buy the
old shows,
I said,
you know,
the old shows aren't going to sound
quite the same because they were good by
2007 podcasting standards.
But the standards of what we all do are
so much higher than when we started
doing them.
You know,
if you grade this on a curve,
go to itunes and look at the stuff
that's up there with you and compare it
to the stuff that was up there 10 years
ago.
I was competing with kids in dorm rooms
10 years ago.
Now we're competing with NPR and I mean
all the pro outfits.
Yeah,
it is the sound quality for sure.
But also like podcast,
you get better at doing it,
you know,
you get better at the flow of the
conversation.
You get better at like being in tune
with the person that you're talking to
or at least attempting to like that.
That's something for people that are
listening.
When you try to consider like how a
podcast is made,
one of the things that we're doing is
we're trying to express ourselves,
but we're also trying to monitor
ourselves at the same time.
Make sure you're not too overbearing or
you're not talking too much.
Or sometimes you have a point and you
just,
Oh my God,
I gotTa make this point.
But the other person's talking,
you don't know when to jump in,
but you also have to listen to the
person who's talking.
So then you forget your point and you're
like,
fuck,
you know,
it's,
it's a weird juggling act because we're
both doing it.
Sort of free balling.
We're both ad libbing,
doing it live.
You know what's happening to me now.
I'm ashamed to say it,
but I was starting to get that,
that thing.
I'm 59,
I turned and I'm starting to get that.
You forget the name or you forget,
you know,
I compare it to a computer.
I have more stuff in my computer,
but the computer is slower than it used
to be.
And so I'll have this point where I'll
be talking and everything will be going
good and then all of a sudden there'll
be this really long pause.
What I can't think of what,
that's where we have to just,
you know,
if there is a bed and he has to cut out
and just eat a sandwich.
The two pieces together.
While I tried to remember the name of
the person I wanted to say or so I'm
getting to the point now where I'm not
sure I could go live anymore without
these really long pauses where I forget
what I was going to say or I forget the
point I was making or the tangent I was
on,
so 10 years from now,
this is going to be very interesting
podcast.
It's also deals with the amount of hard
drive space you have.
I think if you told her remembering
things like there's things that I used
to know so well just 10,
15 years ago that I just have pushed
aside because I haven't brought it up in
a long time.
I haven't gone into that folder in my
mind in the tabs now.
Yeah,
and if I went to try to pull it out now
it's like,
no,
we're,
we're our space on the warehouse floor
is filled bro.
There's no room for that.
And the bus isn't what it used to be
asked.
The Bas speed is not what it used to be,
but I try to crank that up with this
stuff.
I'm so much healthier than I am.
Well,
this is coffee.
This is not how.
I mean it's kind of healthy,
but it's really just speed.
Where I come from.
Coffee is health food.
What?
Oregon?
Oregon healthiest.
Fuck.
Yeah.
Well there's a couple of people that
aren't so healthy in Oregon just in that
I'm leading the charge.
Do you like living up there in the
Pacific northwest?
You know,
I'm from here and,
and,
and coming back home is weird because I
told my,
my wife recently see my kids are
Oregonians and I haven't gotten used to
that fact.
It just seems weird to me and I told her
I still feel like this Angeleno up in
Oregon,
but I've been there 20 years.
I don't know.
When you start feeling,
I mean you're from the east coast to
research.
Do you feel like you're an Angeleno or
do you still think of yourself as a
transplant?
I've been here for 22 years as long as
I've been in Oregon,
so I've been here forever.
So you feel like this is home.
I've lived here more than I've lived
anywhere in my life.
When you go home with home,
when you go back to where you were from,
does it feel like coming home or does it
feel foreign?
It feels weird.
I'm used to make me insecure,
like I used to go a look where my high
school was and I would.
It would bring back the feelings of
being in high school again.
When I was.
When I graduated from high school,
I would have nightmares that I didn't
graduate and I'd have to go back.
That's pretty classic.
The algebra class I forgot that you
didn't drop or whatever.
Yeah.
And yeah,
I felt like I had to go back like,
oh no,
I'm gonna.
I'm gonna fucking have to drop out or
I'm going to have to go back to school
at the dread of the.
And it wasn't like the school was so
horrible.
It was really like the uncertainty of
the future and life and the insecurity
and the,
just the,
the angst that teen angst of,
you know,
slowly realizing that we're not even
slowly realizing but becoming an adult
and knowing that it's just a few years
away that I'm going to be completely
responsible for myself,
but I'm completely lost,
you know,
so there's is unbelievable pressure that
comes with going from being a teenager
to a time.
It's really mean to say unbelievable is
nothing to compare to be like growing up
a kid in Laos,
you know,
or you're living in fucking Somalia in
the middle of,
you know,
all sorts of different crisis that are
going on.
So it's really like the most privileged
angst possible.
Home.
Reasonably the same when you go back to
the sea,
because I come back here,
I told my mom I was reading this.
I'm reading this book written by a,
if you remember,
uh,
William Buckley,
the famous,
you know,
talk,
talk to his son,
wrote a book about,
you know,
his dad getting old and getting ready to
pass away and whatever.
And at one point his dad who was in
Florida said he wanted to go home to
die,
which I guess was Connecticut and he
said dying in Florida was like contrary
to nature.
So we wanted to go home where everything
was the same.
And I thought to myself,
if I went home to die home is anything
like home was I drive to the places I'm
from and it doesn't even know it doesn't
ring a bell anymore.
The place,
if I wanted to go home to die,
I'd have to have a time machine,
you know,
because everything is so different to if
every fifth,
for those who don't know Los Angeles,
like every 15 years,
bulldozes itself and rebuilds itself.
And so I'm like three generations of La
bulldozing from where my time was.
And so I go up and down these streets.
It looks like a foreign city to me.
Now also,
the mass exodus of people is never
subsided.
A lot of them are in Oregon now.
Just so you don't mean we've got better
restaurants in better theater and
everything because of all the
California's that go.
Yeah.
But when I first moved up there,
if you had a California license plate
that was like an invitation to have your
car get keyed.
Yeah.
Oh,
the California's were not popular in
Colorado either.
When I went to school there,
California Californians were not
popular.
Now I think probably x Californians are
like the majority.
Yeah.
That's the case with boulder.
I remember when I was living in Boulder,
they said that a lot of people moved up
right after the earthquake.
I lived in boulder to four years.
Yeah.
I went to school there.
People will like check please soon as
the ground starts shaking boulder,
um,
seven years ago,
seven years ago.
So there before the podcast for the
podcast started.
Did you like it?
I was only there for a few months.
I was there for four months.
We planned on living there for a year
then maybe permanently.
But along the way my wife got pregnant
and we were at 8,500
feet above sea level.
That's right.
Yeah.
And it was just brutal.
They say that Colorado in general,
like around the Denver area has a very
high rate of premature births.
And low birth weight because of the lack
of oxygen I would never have thought.
I would've thought you'd have your kid
born with like superhuman lungs be like
one of those Sherpas in Tibet.
Well I think if you live there and you
grow up there,
probably like if you live there and grow
up there.
Like I was talking to an endurance
runner that lives there and he said it
takes three years for the body to
completely acclimate where you get all
the benefits of training up there.
But I have all the Olympic guys.
You do the bicycling and everything up
there too,
just because of the altitude.
Well,
yeah,
that's a big thing with any sort of
athletic competition training that
involves endurance training at altitude.
It makes a big difference,
but I think if you lived there your
whole life,
your body's accustomed to it,
you're adapted to it.
It's probably fine for your kids because
obviously a lot of people who have kids
in Colorado,
but I think that if you were from sea
level like here and then you go there,
it's quite a shock to your system.
Like you tried to go up a flight of
stairs and you're like,
Whoa,
I'm Kinda remind you.
Doesn't mean for sure if you were at 80
something.
I mean that's,
that's tired and boulder.
You must've been out in the mountains.
Yeah,
we're in the mountains.
It,
yeah,
85,
8,500
feet above sea level.
It's a.
But when you work out there,
man,
it's,
it's crazy.
The,
the,
the impact.
Like if you're just standing around
talking,
it seems normal.
Like if you and I were having this
conversation up there,
it wouldn't be any different,
but if you had to walk up a flight of
stairs or climb a ladder or something
like that,
all of a sudden you're like,
Jesus Christ.
I age 30 fucking years in 10 minutes.
But anyway,
going back to my high school,
when I go to my neighborhood where I
grew up in,
it looks pretty much the same so it
hasn't really blown up.
But I grew up in Newton,
upper falls,
Massachusetts,
which is a small,
like a suburb of Boston.
So it's a small place.
It's always been small lets you go back
there.
It's kind of similar.
Like I went back to the house where I
grew up like about a year and a half ago
and it's pretty much the same.
Wow.
I'm jealous because I go to these
websites that say you know,
the San Fernando Valley in the 19
seventies and look at pictures and it's
nothing like it looks now you have to go
to Jerry's Deli and look at those old
pictures.
They have to.
I have books actually had.
And this is funny,
as I get older,
I'd ever cared about La history when I
lived here,
but now that I'm getting nostalgic and
stuff,
I buy all these old books with pictures
of Magic Mountain when I was a kid in
Disneyland when I was a kid.
And all those kinds of things.
What's fascinating because this area
used to be ranches.
Oh yeah.
Oh.
And horse country and having.
Absolutely.
Well I took my wife back to my high
school recently and you know,
my high school's turned into like,
you know the Beverly Hills high school
is when it's like.
And so she looks at me,
she goes,
oh,
I see how you were raised,
honey.
No,
it's melt like manure.
It was all dirt roads.
It was really.
It wasn't like that for me.
So she doesn't believe me.
Yeah.
The pictures at Jerry's Deli on Ventura
up here,
they have these pictures from the early
19 hundreds of these big giant high
resolution photos and it's like wow,
fields and stuff.
Rolling Hills.
You could look at an a timelapse just
watch it all,
watch it all build.
You'd be like,
Whoa,
what the.
My Mom's got this view of the entire
valley and you look at it and it's full
and you see those pictures from Jerry's
Deli and it's empty and it basically,
whatever it is,
70 years or something.
It's full.
Yeah.
Well,
the whole country,
if you really stop and think about,
I've been talking to people about that a
lot lately because we've been sort of
discussing how bizarre this,
uh,
election has been and how recent this
country has existed.
How recent is recently this country was
established.
I mean,
when you think about 17,
76 and you think about the rest of the
world,
like this is an insanely new country.
Oh,
in the west.
My,
my wife's grandfather died recently.
He was 94 and I said,
do you realize that two of your
grandfather's lifespans and there is no
non natives here on the west coast.
That's too long.
Lifetime.
Yeah.
It's bizarre.
It's really interesting when you think
about it that way.
How quick this gigantic thing it took
over the world.
Essentially.
I should correct the.
See,
I already heard it.
Hardcore history error in that comment I
should say in the Pacific northwest
because they'll say,
oh no,
Dan,
they were Spanish missions.
And see that's how you get in trouble.
Okay.
We go three generations.
Three generations now.
The Spanish were here a long time ago,
but,
but up in the Pacific northwest,
he wasn't like that.
There were,
you know,
because it's funny,
you can tell where the tide of,
of Spanish conquest sort of broke
because you,
you,
you stop getting those Hispanic names
for all the communities and all of a
sudden you're like,
what happened to Lahabra?
What happened to all those wonderful
Spanish names and you're no longer in
that.
Now you're in Russia actually owned a
little bit of that territory once upon a
time,
but now you're,
everything's a native American name or,
or some name from some really early
settler or pioneer or something like
that.
We were talking about how recently
slavery existed in this country.
Oh my God,
yes.
18,
65.
And you think about 18,
65 to 2016 is nothing.
Well,
and then let's remember that.
You know,
you still had the Jim crow laws and
segregation up until you and I were
kids.
My mom did a film in Florida in 1972 and
I'm not talking about the apologies to
floridians out there,
but the civilized part of Florida,
we were in the swamp.
It was a place called Weeki wachee if
you've ever been there.
The big draw is they have a live mermaid
show that they try to get you to slow
down for enough to eat at the local cafe
or whatever.
And so we're in Weeki wachee Florida.
We took a picture when we left and the
whole hotel staff was out there and it
looks like something out of a time more
because you realize you're like three or
five years of segregation has been gone
that long.
I mean that's how recent this is.
Although I realized the more I talk to
young people,
even being 50 sounds like a long time
ago,
but when you and I were kids,
that was the tail end of the time when
if you were a black person in certain
states in this country,
you couldn't stay in a bunch of hotels.
I mean,
that's,
that's really recent.
Yeah,
Um,
I had this cop on my from Baltimore,
Michael Wood,
and he was telling me about the laws
that they had in Baltimore,
that they had a systematic,
they really had racism that was so a
part of the city that you couldn't sell
houses in certain areas to Bach people.
Frank Robinson tells a story about being
with the Baltimore Orioles and he says
he got traded from the Cincinnati reds,
the Baltimore Orioles,
and his wife was able to find a house
really quickly until they realized it
wasn't Brooks Robinson's wife who's a
white guy.
It was Frank Robinson's wife.
And then all of a sudden the house
disappeared right off,
you know,
two seconds later.
So,
but that's almost a,
you know,
you don't know what to say about that
because there's two kinds of racism.
There's the kind where the government is
involved in the states involved,
like you said,
system institutionalized.
And then there's,
I'm a white home buyer whose neighbors,
you know,
I remember there was an all in the
family episode where Archie bunker or
one of the neighbors was going to sell
to a black family.
And all the other white neighbors
freaked out.
So I mean that's not really like
government racism.
That's like good old fashioned one to
one racism,
you know?
Well they used to do this thing called
blockbusting and it happened with my
grandfather.
My grandfather lived in Newark,
New Jersey.
And these realtors would go door to door
and literally tell the homeowners,
black people are moving into the
neighborhood.
You have to sell your home and the
property values are going crash.
People
just.
They just started selling like crazy.
My grandfather stayed.
My grandfather was like,
I like black people,
get the fuck off my lawn.
He was one of those guys.
So they,
they left in the neighborhood changed.
First it became black,
then it became Puerto Rican.
And then before my grandfather died it
had been like a weird mixture of
ethnicities,
Dominicans and different people from
different environments.
But it was a really fascinating place to
live because there was extreme,
there was poverty and then there was a
lot of crime and stuff.
Like the next door neighbor when my
grandfather lived there is a kid who was
selling crack and they battering rammed
his front door.
He had it all reinforced everything.
Had An audi in the driveway,
like the whole deal.
He was just selling drugs and they,
you know,
broke down as doorway and arrested.
I've never thought it was a pretty
dramatic moment,
but the rest of it was like when you
look at like a bad neighborhood,
it's not like you go down the street and
it's like a war zone.
Guns are going off and people getting
stabbed for the most part.
It's pretty friendly and lively.
It's just when you're dealing with poor
people in a crime ridden neighborhood,
you know,
it's just gonna happen more often than
it's going to happen in a place that's
really nice.
But most of the time when you go outside
it would be people playing music and
there was kids playing in the street and
it was people hanging out in their
steps.
It was really interesting to watch like
his,
you know,
from the time I was a little kid
remembering his name,
you know,
his neighborhood to what it was before
he died and it had just kept shifting
over and over again.
We're new,
new,
sort of a lower income,
disenfranchised groups would move into
the area.
And you know,
this I'm sure already,
but for the listeners state,
there's a whole theory on how if you
look at boxing,
you can see,
you know,
who the wave of immigrants most recent
was because boxing became a way for
people to get out of the ghetto.
And so if you look at,
say,
early 19 hundreds up into the middle,
19 twenties and thirties,
there were a lot of Jewish boxers
because their parents had come over on
the boat and they were first generation
Italian boxers during the same period.
Irish boxers.
Uh,
and then you move to areas where,
I mean poor African Americans have
always been in boxing for.
Because for the same reason,
Hispanic boxers,
I mean,
I saw a whole article once on America's
immigration story as told through
boxing.
And they would suggest that by the time
the next generation came along,
most of the time the parents had done
well enough so that,
you know,
the kids didn't have to go into boxing,
but.
But it was an interesting story that,
you know,
I think it was,
I think the article was entitled
something like,
why don't you see any great Jewish
boxers anymore?
And it went down the whole list and I
didn't know there were Jewish boxers
when I first.
Oh,
Benny Leonard.
There a lot of Jewish maxie Rosenbloom.
A lot of them.
Yeah.
There was a,
there was a ton of them,
the early days.
But it's always that.
It's always the immigrants first
generation people,
right?
Yeah.
Well we've seen a lot now is Russians.
Same.
Same system though,
right?
You have,
you have newcomers who are trying to
make their way into the system and
boxing is the best thing they bring to
the table.
Yeah.
It's also that you,
growing
up in these really hard environments
were fisticuffs are much more common and
people seek to train themselves to learn
how to fight because they're dealing
with conflict all the time.
Absolutely right.
Whereas a lot of the kids in class,
you see,
you know,
America,
no bullying,
you know,
hey,
diversity and these kids are growing up
and they,
you know,
they just no desire for the average
middle class white kid to go into
boxing.
It's just no desire.
Those of us who've tried it,
I tried it once just for the fun of it
and that was enough to kick me out of
the.
I didn't,
didn't look so fun anymore after I came
home with a black eye and I thought
that's just one day at practice.
You know,
these people who do it for a living
that's everyday,
but you only try.
You try it for one day.
Oh,
well,
you know,
I was like,
this is crazy to say now.
I've always been a huge fan of boxing
because I grew up in an era where it was
one of the great errors in boxing
history and so you know,
you think long enough that you want to,
you want to see what it's like,
and I had a buddy that I worked with,
he was the one who showed up with the
black guy after the weekend was over and
he said,
I'll take him,
we'll fool around.
The first thing I learned that I didn't
know is how much some of these guys just
love it because you think who would like
getting hit?
And I met one of these guys and he was
like,
you don't understand the sport,
you just don't understand it,
but season he's put some gloves on.
We'll go in there.
Well that's when you learn,
you know,
especially I have a soft face.
That's,
that guy's an asshole.
That's not how you're supposed to teach
somebody about boxing.
You're not supposed to even think about
sparring for a long time.
Paul,
I think he was going to show me a lesson
and these gonna Cheat on you.
That's right.
Yeah.
I had a buddy of mine do the same thing,
assholes.
They know how to quite already and they
put gloves on.
You beat the shit out of you.
He was waiting with one punch,
Joe,
let's not make it more one that I
learned my lesson pretty fast.
I'm a smart guy.
Joe took one punch and you're like,
okay,
got through my defense with the first
one and that was it.
Well,
you need to learn stuff.
This is like boxing the way.
It really should be taught to someone.
If you really want someone to learn,
you should teach them the proper
fundamentals on how to move their body
and then you slowly teach them how to
slowly hit things.
How about protective head gear for the
new guy?
What about that?
That protective headgear does less than
you think.
I know I've read that actually there
also,
they're also removing it from Olympic
competition.
Now you ever see that?
You know,
I had mentioned to my wife,
didn't they used to have boxing in the
Olympics?
Do they even just show it anymore?
Did they show it because I didn't see
it?
You don't see it as much.
I was so big when I was a kid.
I wonder what they decide to put on and
how they decide.
It's got to be based on ratings.
Right?
Because like archery,
you see archery for like 30 seconds.
Look,
the Arrow flew through the air next.
You know,
and then gymnastics is always a big one.
People have watched people flip.
I told my wife there was this
competition called a biathlon will you
ski and shoot?
And she said,
you're making that up.
I said,
no,
it's really an Olympic sport.
It is a weird sport.
Right.
What a strange combination with those
scandinavians just kick everybody's rear
end.
Yeah,
because they're all out there skiing and
shooting.
Exactly right.
It's rude.
It's a lot of moose in that area.
That's a strange.
The Olympics are strange in what is a
metal and what is not like.
Ballroom dancing is an Olympic
synchronized swimming.
That's an Olympics.
I'm not denigrating anybody.
If you're a professional synchronized
swimmer,
I am.
I'll take the blame.
That's.
Please do a lot like curling.
Ever seen that one?
Yeah.
That's another one.
I always thought that was what they did
on like cruises for old people,
but apparently it's a little bit
shuffleboard.
It's very close.
There's no brooms involved in.
Shuffled.
Does no brooms and know what's curling.
You're trying to drink the other guy out
of the way.
Right.
Trying to knock your.
It's very complicated.
I never quite mastered the.
I was in Newfoundland.
I know how to say it now because people
got mad at me because I said,
oh,
we're calling new found blend that gets
its newfoundland.
They're probably correct.
Correct me again.
I'm probably fucking it up again.
I'm not even going to try,
but I was making fun of curling and they
went crazy.
They were so upset at me.
I was like,
come on folks.
Those are not people to get get mad at
you either.
They're hardy.
Say it's very cold.
Yeah.
Different kinds of different kind of
life,
but what I don't know what.
What do they do to decide like what goes
on the air?
It must just be based on popularity.
Right?
The Olympics.
I got to tell you,
if I'm the.
If I'm the network executive deciding
what goes on the air,
that's what I'm going to base it on.
Did you see all those videos of people
getting robbed that were just walking
down the street and Rio?
Rio?
No,
but I go to a website sometimes when I'm
bored and have nothing better to do that
is just,
you know,
stuff that people upload,
just to blow your mind and say wow,
that and half of them are from Brazil
for some reason,
you know,
and they're always terrible.
You just go.
I know it's giving me a,
um,
an unusually wrong version of what
Brazil is light,
but when they said the Olympics,
we're going to be there.
I said,
do you know half the videos on this site
or from Rio?
So.
Well,
it's,
it does have a history of violence,
that's for sure.
It's a strange place and that's kind of
the reverse of la in that La you,
you essentially have the expensive homes
in the hills and then the people that
have the less expensive homes are on the
bottom.
But in Rio it's the opposite.
The people on the bottom,
like near the ocean,
it's the really expensive homes and up
in the hills with this amazing views are
all the favelas.
So it's all these houses that don't have
any windows.
Some of them have dirt floors and
there's like extreme extreme poverty.
I know some of these communities they
can't eat.
The police can't even go into right
somehow.
Really hardcore.
Very.
Did you ever see city of God the movie?
No,
but I saw the preview.
Does that count?
Does not count,
but it's,
it makes Boyz in the hood look like Mary
poppins and it's based on life in the
favela is like really,
really based on it.
Like these kinds of actual scenarios
actually do take place where young kids
with guns form gangs and you know,
you're,
you're looking at like 10 year old kids.
Doesn't.
That almost seemed to be like a law of
nature though because you do see it
everywhere in these.
When you go to the poor countries or
poor parts of the US,
like you said,
uh,
you were talking about how the poor
communities are,
are pretty much like the nicer
communities in some ways.
I used to have to go down to compton all
the time when I worked in news down here
and Compton in the daytime.
It looks just fine.
People are trying to keep their lawns
mowed.
They're out there working on their
homes.
I mean everything.
It's when darkness falls that things can
get a little weird on certain street
corners and,
and whatnot.
But you know,
I remember going down,
they just think,
boy,
everybody here is really trying,
you know,
I mean,
they're really keeping up their homes
and trying to make everything nice.
And,
and at nighttime they're just victims.
A lot of the time,
you know,
they shut their doors and close their
windows and try to stay out of what's
going on outside.
It is weird that it's night,
like there's something happens to people
when there's not as much people that
sleep all day.
I used to be one of those people once
upon a time,
but compton,
like if you looked at a good
neighborhood,
like how many people are getting by and
how many people are fucking it up,
you know,
in a great neighborhood.
Maybe it's like 100 people are getting
by and one guy's fucking it up.
You like one issue out of 100.
But in compton it might be three and
that's enough.
That's enough to give the whole
neighborhood a black guy.
You're right.
It doesn't take very many.
That's right.
Yeah.
A friend of mine has a gym in Compton
and I was telling we were headed there
and I was like,
yeah,
it's in Compton.
My,
the guy I was going with like,
Jesus,
we're going to compton.
I was like,
it's a fucking wrong.
It's just a city.
It's just go there.
What does this compton cowboys.
I just googled compton in his story.
Just came up from yesterday.
What's the fuck is this the guys that
ride horses through Compton?
I guess it's even legal.
I didn't know you could do that in la
because,
uh,
like in New York they have to have a
device that hooks up to the horse so it
doesn't,
you know,
have manure on the streets.
How did they get around that?
There is lyrice cowboys roping and
riding right in the heart of Compton
have found their hobby contains some of
the most dangerous neighborhoods.
I have a regular nine to five job,
but I'm a cowboy.
Hossley said good for him.
I'm in favor of that.
But you're not a cowboy.
Keep the horse.
First of all,
there's no cows.
You're a horse boy.
What do you.
You're in a horses.
Is that a backyard horse?
I mean,
we beat that.
It must be.
Well,
there's some.
I mean I know that like I've seen them
in Burbank,
Burbank.
There's sections of a,
which is where NBC is.
Jay Leno tonight show the sections of
that that are at question.
So you're allowed to have a stable in
your yard and people will just ride
horses down the street.
You see it all the time.
They used to have a place called
pickwick stables right outside of
Burbank that was like that.
Yeah.
They used to have the equestrian center
down there when I was a kid 50 years ago
or whenever it was.
Yeah.
Horse Horse riding makes you a cowboy.
You'd not accounting less cows are
involved.
Is that the Rogan standard on that?
Just think that's a fact.
I just think that's the fact that your
horsepower,
will you call them cowboys?
Because they would chase cow.
They would herd them,
you know.
Okay,
I'll go with you.
I just don't have the expertise to
compete on that subject.
They have the competition policy.
What does is they have an actual ranch
called richland farms.
I was just looking at it up,
try to find out like more pictures or
what it really looks like,
you know,
I'll tell you.
Educated.
I was.
I didn't know they had enough open
property out there to look at that.
Yeah.
Wow.
So they have chickens and shit.
I'm impressed and these guys are doing
little things with their horses where
they're running them through routine for
them.
Interesting.
Very interesting.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what man,
when people find open spaces and spaces
that are vacant and they start
reclaiming them and occasionally good
things come out of that and you know
what,
there's a lot of cities in the United
States and in Europe and stuff that that
had built giant open spaces,
you know,
whether it's a central park in New York
or anything like that.
It changes the whole feel of these urban
centers don't have to have big open
pieces of territory in the midst of the
urban sprawl.
I mean,
if that's what they'd done,
got more power to them.
La needs more of that.
I think you're right.
And it keeps it from growing.
Like one of the really smart things that
Boulder's Don's,
they buy up all the open space when lots
are available all around boulder.
They just buy it up,
the city buys it up and they just
prevent people from building on it.
That's why it costs like $9,000
a month to have an apartment in boulder.
Yeah,
it's super expensive,
but you know,
I mean ultimately it's probably a good
idea,
right?
Oh yeah.
Well,
from it from your own living purposes.
Absolutely.
So I mean that's what I want.
I look in Oregon.
I can park anywhere.
I tell Angelenos that near that.
Really the only people,
New Yorkers and Angelenos understand
when you say I can park anywhere dude.
And they just go,
Oh really?
Yeah.
My Buddy Steve moved from New York.
He was living in Brooklyn and he moved
to Seattle and he was like,
I should have been here a long time ago.
Oh totally.
He's like fucking traffics.
Nothing.
He's like,
people are complaining but they don't
know like it takes 10 minutes more to
get where you're going.
That's it right now.
And you know,
nowadays,
I mean in the old days if you and I
wanted to work,
you had to live where the work was now.
I mean even the actors don't live here
much anymore,
you know?
Yeah.
Well Open space I think is a really
smart thing because people left their
own devices will really fuck up
anything.
They'll just build on top of shit and
stack things up and stuff.
People in there.
And next thing you know,
the views gone.
Everything's gone,
chicken ranch next to your house.
It's one of the things that this country
has.
It's really interesting is public land,
these gigantic national parks like
yellowstone,
all these different places that you can
go to.
Mostly in the West though,
you know,
that was a win,
that sage brush rebellion type thing
happened up in Oregon.
You know what?
The one area where they're still having
trials about and everything that the
were they see 20 years ago I would have
remembered their names right off the
bat,
but there's a wilderness thing up in
Oregon.
We had that whole thing.
Well,
their complaint was that the federal
government doesn't have big tracks of
land in the eastern part of the country
where things started.
They reverted that land back to the
public,
but they had these huge swaths of land
in the West because it was kind of a
different government by the time they
were out here in the west.
I truthfully,
I'm kinda thankful they do because if
they didn't,
it wouldn't be here anymore.
I mean,
that's the way I look at it and just be
gone.
Yeah.
Most likely that that whole land thing
was really confusing for people.
They were trying to figure out what the
hell is going on because if you.
Unless you really dive into the story
and try to find out who's angry at who
and why is the government moving in on
these people and what's what's
happening.
Because there was a few of these sort of
rancher type disputes with the
government.
Remember there was one in Nevada as
well.
I actually can speak to this a little
bit because what I was a talk radio host
up there.
Those people were actually a large part
of any talk radio show audience and they
were a little different back in the day
of say the Clinton administration in the
mid 19 nineties,
but.
But the modern movement kind of grew out
of that and if you understand the
position of those people in those small
towns,
those people essentially made a living
in resource extraction so they didn't
have the big factories that they had
back east and Detroit and everything.
They logged or they mind or they did
those kinds of things and so when the
government will decide,
for example,
we have a problem with the spotted owl,
so we're going to cut back on the
logging.
The people in places like Portland where
everybody's got a software job or
something,
they they're like,
absolutely,
that's a wonderful thing,
but those devastated some of those
communities and you know,
it's everything from the schools in
those areas not getting a lot of tax
dollars anymore or the problem they have
an Oregon.
There's a lot of those small
communities.
All the young people are gone because
there's no jobs.
So the old people who have homes stay,
there's no jobs because everybody was in
logging and they get very resentful.
So when they wanted the public land
turned over to private people because
they were hoping the private people
would start off the meals again and
people could work.
So in that sense,
I felt like the media really didn't
really didn't look at that side of the
story,
which is.
I'm not saying these people are right or
wrong,
but understand that this wasn't a
question of the government's got to get
off of our net.
It was jobs and I think we can all
understand jobs.
Well,
what was going on in Oregon was cattle,
ranchers and public land and they
decrease.
Hey,
today's.
Yeah.
They didn't want to pay for public land.
Now,
before I had ever ventured into public
land,
I didn't understand the whole cattle
grazing thing,
but when I was in the first time I was
in Montana,
we went,
uh,
we took a float down the Missouri River.
We went down to where the Missouri
Breaks and Montana's beautiful.
Oh man,
it's amazing.
But one of the things I was like,
there's these cows everywhere.
Like,
is it,
this is public land,
right?
And um,
my friend Steve had a sort of explained
to me how they kind of leased the land.
They let cows graze this land and they
do it at this riddick.
Yes.
They made a lot of these laws in the
late 18 hundreds of safety with the
mining ones in the claims to that.
So they have updated a lot of those
things,
um,
but then Nevada guys,
or excuse me,
the Oregon guys,
they didn't want to pay.
That was part of what was going on.
They didn't want to pay their bill to
least as far as experience
and there's different parties involved.
So you had these ranchers,
he didn't want to do that and then you
have a bunch of people in the community
who were sympathetic,
not so much to that part,
but the fact that the ranchers were mad
at the same people that they were mad
at.
So,
so,
so that's why you hear a lot of people
speak in these things saying I'm not
really,
you know,
on their side,
but we all generally have sympathy to
the idea that we would like the federal
government to stop telling us how many
logs we can cut or those kinds of
things.
And that's a traditional American thing.
Get the government off my back and
whatever
it is.
And there's points on both sides though,
unfortunately.
Oh absolutely.
Because when you look at,
like when you look at some that's been
clear cut and you see like how much it's
devastating.
It's devastating when you see a giant
swath of land that used to be filled
with old growth trees and they replanted
with a single mono crop instead and use,
you know,
they always call it like they want you
to think it's like growing tomatoes,
you know,
they always say this is a renewable crop
and yes and no.
And,
and like you said,
the clear cuts are awful because you do
think to yourself,
couldn't you take like every fifth tree
or a lot of times private land owners
will do a better job of it.
Not always.
Sometimes they'll just think my kid
needs to go to college.
It's time to just level everything on
this hill.
Sometimes though they're attitude is
okay,
this is my view.
I mean I look out,
I don't want to see a clear cut as well.
I'll take every third or fourth tree
and,
and it becomes like a,
an extra bank account for some of them.
So.
Well,
it's if your whole business is the
logging business,
I can imagine like we were up in the
redwood forest recently and as we were
driving up there,
you pass these lumber yards.
There was this one lumber yard where
it's just massive logs and massive
amounts.
They're just stacked up and you're
looking at like in terms of the number
of years of growth you're looking at
when you're looking at this huge lumber
yard filled with trees,
like how many years of growth is that?
How do you sustain it?
Right?
I mean if this is how much you need
today,
how do you make sure you have that much,
15,
20 years?
You know,
what they're doing right now is,
is the Canadians are logging a lot and
in Russia,
in the places like below the,
the,
they have a forest line in Siberia and
they're logging a lot there too.
I mean it's Kinda like gold that grows
for those people.
And so in one sense you find it hard to
tell them not to because I'm doing just
fine,
but you can't log and make money.
And the other hand,
you know,
we all do kind of share this and so it's
hard to figure out how to manage things
she does for the greater good as they
say.
That's the good point is that it's
really,
I mean,
it's no ones you could call it property,
but what it is,
is like we're all sharing the resources
of the earth and what's going on in the
Amazon right now.
And uh,
what happens when people move in and
farm for cattle is one of the best
arguments against factory farming and
against supporting the meat industry
pollutes rivers and all that devastating
deforestation to at a ridiculously high
rate.
That's a big part of what's going,
what's fueling the deforestation is they
chopped down all these trees so that
they can make gland for these cattle to
graze on.
And you can see by the way,
how much money is involved because some
of the,
in some of those countries,
the people that campaign,
a lot of times they're indigenous
people,
it gets violent and people die.
And you know what I mean?
That's how much money we're talking
about.
Yeah,
they killed.
They were killed some nun that was
protesting against the logging she got
murdered recently.
It's not that uncommon.
And,
and,
and you know,
everybody kind of knows this is,
you know,
you're taking.
I mean,
it's pretty brave when you think about
what those people do because they get
the threatening letters long before
happens to them
and then to keep doing it.
I admire people like that and whether or
not I agree with a specific cause.
Yeah.
I mean who knows if they're even getting
letters,
you know,
they just might get bullets.
You know what I mean?
If you start making a massive,
making a lot of noise and making it
problematic for the people that are
earning a shitload of money,
chopping those trees down,
things can get real ugly.
They get real nasty.
I was in Mount Rainier and that was the
first time I ever saw like real clear
cut areas and that's an interesting
place because it rains so much,
you would think like it's a real fertile
environment,
like whatever trees that they do have.
But when I was talking to one of the
guys was up there,
one of the cops that was um,
uh,
you know,
it was a forest ranger type character.
Uh,
he was saying that they do it,
but it takes like 20 years for these
things become trees again.
Well,
and they use different growth trees for
different things.
So you can grow the quick,
you know,
I always hear from the guys who want to
grow hemp and say,
well,
if they would just grow hemp,
it would make it.
But it would make up for some uses.
The old growth trees,
they'll like,
if you go into some of these,
there are some Oregon hotels for
example,
they're all built with old growth and
you go in there and you see what old
growth can do and you say,
okay,
there are no other logs that you could
do this with.
You know,
it's just a,
it's a,
you see the band saws that they use to
cut that stuff.
It's,
it's a whole different level of tree.
But the replacement time periods,
like a hundred and 50 years or something
for those kinds of things.
Yeah,
it's kind of fucking crazy.
We didn't really think about it.
It's totally unsustainable,
but you're right,
it looks nothing like it.
There's a company called urban hardwoods
and they're in Seattle.
I've heard of them and they make like
tables and desks and stuff out of the
most incredible looking.
Would they take like real wood,
like a real giant tree and they'll turn
that giant tree.
They'll cut chunks out of it and turn it
into a table,
but it's got like the outside edge.
It's like the natural edge of the tree.
I used to know a guy who was a big
investor.
He's dead now,
but he would find investments to go to
go by and he went and somehow he was so
proud of this.
He'd got himself a piece of a Koa Wood
forest in Hawaii and he showed me the
deed and the deed from the guy he bought
it from had been signed by light King
Kamehameha or something.
So he was bragging to me for years about
this and then found out later Hawaii
wouldn't let him cut any of it.
So He.
He bought it all on the premise that I
had this valuable would and but for
environmental and heritage reasons why
you wouldn't let him,
he was totally screwed.
Wow.
Well,
at least you got a cool forest,
a gorgeous heart and valuable and rare.
Yeah.
I don't think many like guitars out of
the.
I know they make pool cues.
They used to make ships out of it.
You know,
like those old wooden ships.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
The different densities of trees and the
different grains and patterns.
And when you look at actual like
hardwood,
it's such a fascinating and Admin,
not invention,
but creation of nature like these,
the,
the variety of the grain and the way
they look.
It's really like a work of art and it's,
it's strange how it affects us visually.
Like if you look at a piece of redwood
that's been polished and sanded and cut,
it's like you see the grain in.
It's like,
wow,
that is so pretty.
You know,
it's,
it's interesting how that affects us.
I'm wondering who's winning the pool for
what they thought we would talk about
today.
How many people had hardwoods?
Nobody there,
right about hemp though.
As far as the construction material,
they make that stuff called hempcrete.
Have you ever seen that?
It's like no product that they make with
hemp.
It's incredibly.
Has incredible installation values.
It's really difficult to light on fire.
It's going to be used a lot up until
about the thirties and forties.
It was a pretty big crop for a lot of
industrial use is everybody.
Everybody who looks into it for five
minutes knows that.
Yeah.
Well that's one of those things were
stoners love to sit down and talk to you
about it.
You know man Henry Ford made the first.
George Washington.
Yeah.
Do George Washington grew pot bro?
Ben Franklin smoked pot.
Yeah.
Yeah,
they probably did good stuff.
Hard to prove.
Yeah.
Well they definitely liked him.
You know,
there definitely were into hemp and they
were definitely into using it as a
commodity and a textile,
you know,
and you can go back and forth about
that.
Like the pay,
the dress like that.
The first tech waste and one of the
first drafts of the declaration of
independence was written on hemp and
parachutes sales sales with a lot of
stuff we used in both world wars for
equipment in fabric,
a lot of stuff like that.
Even the term canvas comes from the word
cannabis because that's what it was.
Made a member that actually.
Yeah.
It's interesting how it's becoming
illegal,
but that's another thing that's really
fascinating about this time.
It's like slowly in your state,
Washington state,
Colorado,
you're studying to see so much money
coming in from it being legal that it's
going to trickle down into other states.
It's almost kind of a great experiment,
isn't it?
And I've.
I've said before and I,
I might've even said on this show,
the very first time we got together,
I think we may have talked about,
you know,
what's going to happen,
we,
because we have this divergence between
the states and the federal government
and as you probably know,
only a couple of weeks ago the federal
government decided to leave marijuana
classified as a schedule one drug for
the same reason they always did.
Which is they say that the research
doesn't show anything and then you find
out what they're not really permitted do
the research.
So it's this catch 22.
So at some point either the feds are
going to have to move toward the states
or somebody going to get into power that
says,
enough of this dichotomy,
we're going to crack down.
I have no idea what that would look
like.
It would look ugly.
You can't crack down.
Now the amount of money that Colorado is
making is changed.
The,
the quality of life for so many people
there,
their real estate values have gone up.
The drunk driving accidents have gone
way down,
drunk driving arrest,
violent crime,
way down.
I mean,
it's really fascinating what's happened
to Colorado.
Look at what the feds have already done
in,
in roundabout ways.
For example,
one of the things that they've said and
some of these places is if you have a
medical marijuana card,
you can't get pain medication prescribed
to you.
If you have a medical marijuana card,
a judge just upheld,
didn't they?
That you.
That you can be denied a gun.
Yeah,
they don't deny people guns for drinking
the pills.
Yeah,
so the only reason that that works is
because you have a disagreement between
state and federal law and they're siding
with the higher law,
which is the way the law is supposed to
work,
but at what point,
at what point do we have such a of a
division between the reality on the
ground in these states and what federal
law says that the rubber's gonna meet
the road somewhere.
I don't know who wins,
but there's going to be a moment where
you have a rubber meets the road moment.
Yeah,
and it's an interesting case with the
National Rifle Association too,
because the NRA,
which is always a course pro gun and
really trying to stop any laws that
infringe upon the rights of people to
uphold the second amendment,
but when you get to this pot thing,
they don't want to fuck with the pot
thing.
I think they did.
I may be wrong about this,
but I do believe that they did come out
and say that you shouldn't be denying
people's rights the better.
I think that.
Well,
there's a lot.
It's in their interest,
it's in their interest to.
There's a lot of closet pot smokers out
there because it's obviously the
stereotype is always been that it makes
you lazy and it makes you dumb and sort
of gives you brain damage and you forget
things that's been shown time and time
again to not be true.
I mean when you are high as fuck,
you do forget things like when you're in
the throws of like that.
I remember reading a study once where
they were studying population in Jamaica
where a lot of these people who were 75
years old had been doing it their whole
lives and they didn't show any.
Anything that would make you your eyes
bulge out,
your hair stand up and made nothing
seemed that out of the ordinary in terms
of whether you're talking about cancer
rates,
are any of these other things.
If there were something like that,
God,
it would be beaten into our head.
Right,
and that's all the contents of
pharmaceutical drugs and all the people
that are making money off of marijuana
remaining in this schedule.
One category which are pretty
significant.
There's a lot of people that make money
off of it.
The category is ridiculous.
I mean,
that's just crazy.
Do you see what's going on in Arizona?
I tweeted about it.
I think yesterday,
these people who were protesting against
marijuana being legalized in Arizona,
that people are spending the most money.
We're talking hundreds of thousands of
dollars to try to keep marijuana illegal
and Arizona are directly tied to
pharmaceutical drugs.
That's directly tied to pain pills,
specifically the stuff that killed
prince.
What's that stuff called?
Fentanyl?
Fentanyl.
Well,
Arizona was a weird state of the two.
They have some very conservative people.
This is the alcohol industry.
Before that there was one.
So that's the alcohol industry.
And then there's also the,
um,
the fentanyl industry.
It might be a little bit earlier to see
if you scroll down a little bit further,
see if you find it.
But it's just bizarre that we allow that
stuff and it's so transparent today as
opposed to this stuff all went on behind
the scenes 100 years ago,
which of course is why marijuana got
made illegal area.
Fentanyl maker donates big to campaign
opposing pot legalization.
That's fast.
Yeah.
There you go.
A $500,000
towards
defeating a ballot initiative that would
make recreational use of marijuana
illegal under Arizona law.
You're just criminals here.
A bunch of crooks.
The fact that you guys would spend that
much money to stop a drug that has
nothing to do with what you do,
but I'll make the case,
and this is pretty much what my
political show has been about since the
very beginning,
is that that's a fact of factor of the
corruption in our system.
Um,
when,
when it's a pay to play system.
Well,
I mean that's how this happens.
If you're going to impact somebody
else's business by legalizing something
else than the way you fight,
that is you go out there and you donate
to the,
to the cause.
I mean,
in other words,
instead of the people getting what they
want,
it's,
it's whomever donates the most.
And I remember Justice Scalia before he
died was part of a ruling where he
basically said,
that's not a,
a,
a bug.
It's a feature.
This is the way the system is supposed
to work,
you know,
money is,
is supposed to represent the views of
people and if it's poor people,
they can bundle it all together and then
if,
if there's no money,
obviously there's not a lot of people
who care and that was the theory,
but what it's really done is,
is mean if you don't have money flowing
into Washington,
you don't count.
You're not at the table.
Right?
So there's whole sectors of the American
society that are essentially
unrepresented because there's no money
coming from them.
That's the real problem.
And wasn't this sort of structure,
the government structure that sort of
enforces that or,
or relies upon that.
It was kind of established before
corporations were and definitely
established before corporations were
allowed to act as an individual and
donate insane amounts of money to
campaigns the problem.
And you look at it and you just.
You can see how it happened because you
could see that that the people that gave
a little money back in the days when you
could only give this much money,
had a little influence.
So what do you want to do?
You want to influence them to let you
give a little bit more and slowly but
surely you evolve into a system.
I mean that was talking to my wife about
this the other day where we were talking
about how it was never a good system,
but it was a fairer system back when I
was a kid in the 19 seventies because
some of the money came from entities
that represented people who were blue
collar people.
So for example,
when unions were big a private employee
unions,
not the public employee unions.
They're so popular now.
So if you were a pipe fitter or a
plumber or those people that had the
electricians had pretty powerful unions,
those people would bundle money and
those unions would give money to
candidates that sort of compensated for
the fact that you had corporate money or
whatever and other directions.
In the 19 eighties when the Democrats
started getting waxed regularly and were
due to Reagan changing tax policies and
whatever else,
we started to get some really wealthy
people and the union started getting
less powerful.
All of a sudden,
you know,
Willie Sutton,
the bank robber was famously asked,
you know,
why do you rob banks?
And he says,
that's where the money is.
Well,
in the eighties,
you know,
after 84,
especially after Mondale got waxed by
Reagan,
they,
that's when superdelegates started to.
They went and they looked and they said,
okay,
what do we need to compete?
Because if you look at the longterm
trends,
the people that Republicans tend to get
money from,
they're just getting more money.
The people that we tend to get money
from or getting weaker,
and that's when,
that's the role Bill Clinton played in
the Democratic Leadership Council where
they basically said we can go and get
money from those same sources.
So they did.
Okay,
so fast forward to now everybody's taken
money from those same sources and the
people that are lower and middle class
have no way to break into that game.
Right?
So if you know Lawrence Lessig,
the Harvard law professor did a great
book called Republic last,
where he pointed out how he went and
interviewed politicians who didn't even
realize there was another side.
Sometimes to the issue they were voting
on because they hadn't heard from any
money.
Right,
so you almost.
You almost felt like a lot of these
people were almost blameless because in
their minds,
well,
nobody cares about this or I would've
had some money coming in for that.
It's strange how the systems evolve,
but the one thing you can say for sure
is you're not getting money from people
who don't have money,
and so eventually we get to this
dichotomy where there's a lot of people
in this country right now.
What's that old line about taxation
without representation.
A lot of people in this country not
represented a 100 percent.
Also,
you have to think about how many people
feel disenfranchised by the system and
it doesn't seem like it's gonna be fixed
anytime soon because the amount of
people that are contributing to these
campaigns,
when you look at the percentage of human
beings on this landmass is very small
and so the amount of people that have
influence,
it's a very small amount of people that
are affecting the lives of a vast
majority of people and it becomes a very
weird sort of a scenario when we
continue with the same representative
government structure that we had back
when it was impossible to communicate
with people and the other side of the
country.
Like you had a Senate,
you know Morse code or a guy on a horse
with a letter.
It was hard,
so this is why they decided to have
representative government in the first
place.
You couldn't communicate with people.
Now that you can.
It's like we,
we,
we really ultimately have to decide.
I think one day it is one person,
one vote,
like do we all as a mass has 300 million
people get to decide.
Like if a hundred 90 million people
think one thing and the rest,
think another thing.
How does this all work out?
Like how do,
how do we decide?
Because right now we have delicates,
we have representatives,
we have senators,
we have all these different people that
sort of a buffer us from the actual
decisions that are being made and I
think as we,
as it becomes easier and easier to
communicate and express your opinions
and give your thoughts on things,
the option of voting online and the
option of voting directly for issues
without representation seems more and
more enticing to people.
Yeah.
But you'd have to change the
constitution and,
and you know,
that'd be a good idea.
So old as fuck.
I hate to.
It depends on.
I'm reading a book right now that talks
about our government actually operating
sort of between the lines of the,
of the constitution.
So there's room to maneuver and over
time for understandable reasons like
security and other things.
I mean the fact that nuclear bombs were
invented,
changed everything that within those
lines there's room to sort of expand
what you can do,
but you do that generation after
generation and then you look around and
go,
how did we get from where we were in
1942 where we are now?
It's almost inexplicably and and
sometimes when I talk about reform,
you try to figure out how you can dial
things back,
but we've come so far beyond any point
you could dial it back to.
It becomes really hard to imagine.
It's like you have an old mainframe
computer that you've patched and patched
and patched,
and the only way now to make any real
reform is to throw the computer out and
buy a new Mac and start from scratch and
nobody can do that.
I mean,
you can't even figure out how to get
that done.
Yeah.
It's almost like we need an asteroid to
take out the grid,
just come down and boom and wreck the
whole.
Just a big earthquake or a title wave
have to be a big thing.
A big,
big thing that unfortunately kills a lot
of people.
Then the government will step in and
say,
well,
you know,
we have to take care of all of you down
and your security martial law.
People on the street corner was a
government's dead or the hits them.
How symbol,
symbol amatic.
It would be symbolic.
It would be rather simple maddox and
ignored with how amazing it would be.
Like if that's the only place where an
asteroid hit,
if it hit the Pentagon and the White
House,
if like this is too broken up.
Chunks of space.
Rock one slams into the Pentagon.
Kills everyone.
Hey Blaine.
Yeah,
the god of terror.
The God of terror.
Yeah,
I mean that is.
That's really almost the only way.
Something has to be catastrophic in
order for them to try to reset and
rebuild a completely new system and then
people would have to agree.
You.
They'd have to get to together and go,
okay,
are we going to go back to that thing
that was written on him by people that
wrote with feathers or are we going to
Redo this?
We're gonna figure this out from a
modern perspective,
knowing what we know now about our
ability to communicate and knowing what
we know now about all the things that
are the founding fathers of this country
did an amazing job of trying to protect
from corruption,
you know,
trying to make sure that their,
their vision of what America could be,
that this experiment in self government
and they put all these safeguards in
play,
but there's no way they could have ever
predicted how far technology would have
taken us in the 200 plus years since
they did that.
There's just no way they,
they,
they couldn't have any idea.
So now that we know where we are now and
we can sort of extrapolate where it's
going to be in the next 50 a hundred
years and maybe plan for the future,
the digital future that we're dealing
with now.
And then we thought it was the case.
We would have put in some,
some things that people would agree with
in regards to like what the NSA got
caught with,
you know,
with the mass surveillance of the.
Let's talk about that for because I was
just going to go there.
You know,
I was thinking not that long ago,
if you could,
if they force you,
because we all understand that that
history is an evolution,
so,
so all of this is the result of decades
and decades and generations of
generations of building stuff on top of
other things,
but if you had to pick the time that was
most transformative for all those you
were talking about,
you have to go back to the United States
between 1947 and 1948.
That's when Harry Truman and the
government passed these rules that made
everything we talk about today,
the NSA,
the CIA,
all those things are developments from
like national security.
I mean NSC.
60 eight is one of those big ones.
A bunch of these rules that created the
modern United States,
we'll call it the secret government that
we know about today.
And you know,
if you go back in time,
you can certainly understand what they
were thinking.
I mean,
you have to remember how crazy it was
after the second world war and this
feeling that the Soviet Union was this
threat to the whole world and now you
have nuclear weapons and can you really
declare war if there's nuclear weapons.
That could be,
you know,
there's a whole bunch of things where
you go here,
kind of get what was going on,
but it didn't take Harry Truman Long,
you know,
after he left office to say I made a few
mistakes including things like the CIA
and whatnot.
But once you start those programs,
there's an autopilot that that happens
and they develop a momentum of their
own.
So if you said today,
because I would make this case,
if you wanted to look at this the way my
stepfather,
when he was a total profit and loss guy,
and you would look at something like the
CIA,
you would say the CIA is a terrible
failure.
They miss all the big things.
Whether it's the fall of the Soviet
Union,
you name it,
right?
The CIA has got major failures and then
you said,
you know,
all the things that they've done that
were nefarious that they shouldn't have.
So if this were a private business,
you'd turn around and go,
well,
listen,
that's a last thing right there.
You know,
let's take that division scrap it
startled you can't do that in a
government for some reason.
It's almost impossible to decide this
whole area has been a failure.
So let's start over and that's the
problem because I'm not sure you can
reform things that are,
that are flawed at the seeds.
Do you know what I mean?
Um,
and,
and the CIA is a perfect example,
but even the NSA,
I mean,
did you see that this week they're,
once again trying to slip a bill and
that would allow the government without
a warrant to track,
you know,
every website you go to an all these
things,
how does this stuff get that far?
They're going,
they're going to attach it to a totally
unrelated bill so that you don't know
about it.
Again,
how do they get away with this?
Most likely it's just justifying
something they're already doing well and
they're legitimately afraid.
There's stuff to be afraid of,
so I don't always,
you know,
you have to cut them a little slack,
but there's no waiting at all about the
downside.
I mean,
it's almost like the only thing we pay
attention to is the terror side of the
ledger.
Not the fact that,
do you John Mccain or Lindsey Graham,
do you really want the government
knowing every webs,
especially Lindsey Graham.
There's got to be some websites there
that he really would not like the
government to know about.
Come on.
At least think about yourself.
You know,
so I don't know how you stop this
dynamic.
We're such a fearful people that that's
what's going to kill us.
Well,
we know what we've done.
Other people we know.
Payback is probably likely.
That's.
And you know what's.
What's really sad is I've always had
this rose colored view of us and I
acknowledged that it's a myth,
but always look at the myth
of America as I call it,
the 19 fifties high school textbook view
of American.
That to me is what I want to move
towards.
So when they talk about creating a more
perfect union,
that to me is the goal and anything that
conflicts with that self image to me is
the problem.
So when you see sometimes how we really
operate anything Dick Cheney does,
um,
and I don't use the word evil,
so I'll use the word nefarious Dick
Cheney is to me when you say what do you
want to avoid in this country?
I want to avoid.
We're Dick Cheney wants us to go because
nothing conflicts with my 19 fifties,
mythological American textbook idea than
what Cheney wants us to be.
And when you look at some of the things
we've done,
some of the things based on that 19,
47,
19,
48 America,
which we thought,
okay,
we have to do everything to stop global
communism.
They're gonna take over the country.
Once you look at some of the things we
did and you realize some of what we're
dealing with today is blowback.
You don't know how to undo that.
I mean,
you almost think it's like permanent
damage.
Look at the way some in the Middle East.
See us.
I mean,
uh,
I'll,
I'll talk to people like I remember
talking to Sam Harris about this and he
was talking about what you have to see
things a certain way and I said yes,
but that's not going to help you solve
the problem.
How do you solve the problem if we've
already,
if we've already soiled our bed so much
that you don't know how to fix that.
You don't have to go and say,
listen,
we're sorry about this.
Can we start from scratch?
You can't do that in foreign affairs.
Just like you can't do it with the
mainframe computer.
That is the government,
you know,
I can't figure out how to,
how to reverse course to a point where
we can once again fix stuff,
right?
It's,
it's too damaged.
I think it just has to dry out slowly
but surely look all the wounds of the
past to heal up and dry out and it just
takes time.
How do you do it when they're still
after?
You mean we've already made enough
people mad at us so that thereafter us.
Well now we have to go protect ourselves
by going and getting them,
so we perpetuate the cycle.
Like I can't figure out how to jump off
the merry go round.
You know what I mean?
I don't think it moves that way.
I think we're trying to make a
battleship move like a race car and I
just think it takes a long time to shift
course and when we're looking at these
people that are in the Middle East that
are opposing the US right now and angry
and want to attack the US right now,
you're most likely never going to get to
them.
You might get to their grandchildren and
I think that might be the only way.
Things slowly but surely settled down
and that's the argument for the NSA and
the CIA to continue to monitor things
that are really kind of ridiculous and
invasive level because there's so many
people out there that hate us or hate
the government.
I hate the military and hate what's
happened to them and so many martyrs are
created.
Every time a drone strike was going to
go.
How do you.
How do you,
how do you get that next generation to
not hate us when we're busy killing
their parents because their parents want
to kill us.
I mean,
that's the cycle and I can't figure out
how to break the cycle.
How do you protect ourselves from their
anti American parents in a way that
doesn't turn them against us to.
Does that make sense?
It's a real.
It definitely makes sense in the.
It's hard.
No one has a real logical answer to
that.
I mean,
he talked to the Ron Paul supporters and
they think we should just separate and
don't police the world and take care of
our own and just stay there and still
people will want to kill us.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And then you talk to the people that are
on the Dick Cheney camp that like you're
out of your mind.
You're living in a dream movie world in
the real world is dirty and nasty and we
need all these people.
We need all these operatives.
We need people constantly monitoring
these hotspots all around the world
because like,
look what's going on in North Korea.
They're fucking testing nuclear bombs
now and you know,
what are we doing?
We're flying by.
We're.
We're making these threatening gestures.
We were flying fighter jets around North
Korea.
It's,
it's,
it's really spooky.
It's spooky because something can happen
and we don't have anybody over there,
you know,
at least as far as I know.
I mean,
I don't know.
Maybe we have some deep,
deep,
deep undercover CIA people working as
North Korean soldiers.
But I'll tell you what upsets me though,
because what we were just talking about,
getting off the merry go round.
It means kind of not perpetuating the
same mistakes we've made before.
But what drives me crazy about our
system is that the people who make
mistakes,
and I've always said,
you know,
you've forgiven people,
make mistakes.
You're gonna make a mistake,
right?
You shouldn't be allowed to make another
one though,
right?
At the highest levels of government when
you send people to war and we shouldn't
have gone to war.
I'll cut you some slack,
but I don't want you then going on cnn
and being the expert who tells us how to
handle the next crisis,
right?
Because your track record sucks.
Dick Cheney's got a terrible track
record.
We still listen to him.
He still gets to be a person who,
who moves the public debate and there's
a lot of people like that.
You look at the John Bolton's.
There's a heck of a lot of these guys
who are consistently and regularly
wrong,
but we put them out there as though,
oh,
this is somebody you should listen to
now.
And the show.
He's going to analyze how we should
handle North Korea.
Yeah,
but he was wrong as heck about Iraq and
all these other things,
so we're going to listen to him on that
next subject.
We don't make people who are wrong in
this country pay the price,
which means you know,
if you're in a private,
if you're a doctor and you screw up a
few surgeries and people who should not
die,
die.
You're done.
You'll be out of business.
They will take your license.
You won't get to kill anymore.
People in government.
You can continue to make these errors
and you,
you'll be promoted.
You'll be in a position to make more.
Yeah,
that'll kill you.
Over the long haul,
do you wonder like what,
what motivation is Dick Cheney have?
I mean,
he doesn't even have a heart.
They took his heart out.
They stuck some cadaver heart in their
worldview,
but it's not a 19 fifties us high school
textbook worldview.
Right?
But I mean,
why is he doing it?
Like what is his motivation for
continuing to keep Pistons on who you
ask?
Sometimes it's money.
Sometimes it's powerful friends.
I've talked to these people and they'll
give you the old.
You don't know how the world works.
Speech.
Right?
And,
and at that point you have to say to
yourself,
okay,
listen,
I know the constitution is just a piece
of paper,
but at some point there's a rubber meets
the road.
That's going to be my word for today's.
Joe Rogan showed me my fly in the
ointment for today's Joe Rogan show.
But there's got to be a point where
somebody has to sit down and say,
look,
we have a constitution that does this.
Here's the way the world really works.
Now either we're going to go back to one
or we're going to discard
one and completely embrace the other.
At this point we embrace the hypocrisy
that we still live like this,
but the world's a difficult,
tough place,
so we're acting like that.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
No,
no,
it does.
It definitely makes sense.
And that dichotomy is what makes so many
Americans angry.
Yeah.
Well,
it's,
it's amazing that we've limited the
amount of attacks on American soil to
nine slash 11 and Pearl Harbor.
Well,
you had the Orlando attack.
It depends on what you classify the
town.
Lando attack was a crazy fuck that lived
in America.
I mean that was a gun wolf stuff.
What's that guy proven to be gay or is
that like what that is?
I'm sure he's okay.
How about that?
But,
but,
but that's a perfect example though,
of,
of why this is so tough to defend
yourself against.
Because.
And this is the same thing by the way,
the country has been worried about
American radicals for decades.
I mean,
you go look at how we treated the 19
sixties leftist radicals that were
putting bombs in the Pentagon and stuff
like that.
I mean,
it always blows my mind to realize that
if those guys were doing that today,
we might waterboard them at Guantanamo,
you know?
Um,
so I think the domestic radical idea has
been something the government's been
worried about since the first red scare
in the 19,
19 era and the anarchists and that whole
era.
Yeah.
And I think whenever you have a
government,
whenever you have people that are in
charge,
there's going to be people that oppose
those people and they're going to try to
go through some people that are opposing
them.
We're going to go through legal channels
and they're going to protest legally and
they're going to organize and give
speeches and other people are gonna say,
look,
that doesn't work.
We're going to do this guerrilla style.
We're going to do this.
So now we come to the hacks,
right?
That's where we're at.
See,
I argued in the last common sense
program that that the hacks are kind of
a chickens coming home to roost thing
that when we deputize our
representatives to keep some secrets
from us,
because we all understand that there's
going to be some of those,
but if you did that in a private
business,
Joe,
if you work for a boss,
you're your.
You're delivering pizzas at the Pizza
Company and the boss says,
do you listen to?
Sometimes I have to have a little
plausible deniability,
so if you have to stamp something top
secret on your,
on your order form,
I won't look at it and we'll all be
cool.
Okay,
so one day you're out with prostitutes
and drinking beer and you don't deliver
your pizza and you think if I put top
secret on this,
the boss won't see it will be great.
I mean,
it's human nature that after a you're
going to start to classify stuff that
really shouldn't be secret,
right?
I W I t and I said this in the last
show,
I talked to an intelligence operative
once.
It wouldn't tell me anything except I
asked him a question once about if you
had to guess what percentage of stuff is
the stuff that Americans would agree
should be kept secret.
He said about 10 percent.
I said,
what's the rest?
He said,
everything you can think of.
cover your own rear end corporate deal
that a senator doesn't want his
constituents to know about for 40 years
because he'll get voted,
you know,
all the and it's.
It becomes a point where when you're
keeping that much stuff from the
American people that they have a right
to know.
It seems to be inevitable that there
will be literally leaks like you're
trying to cover too much.
Damn.
With,
with two little concrete.
It's natural.
I think in some of these guys like
William beneath the one that everybody
knows.
He said,
I went through every channel I was
supposed to go to and I ended up with
officers pointing federal agents,
pointing machine guns at me as I came
out of the shower.
So when when the system breaks down to
the point where the whistleblowers go
through the proper channels and they
become the ones who get into trouble
than you're asking for leaks and it's
hard to say,
I feel sorry for you that they leaked
that vital information,
but if you haven't been keeping nonvital
information from us for so long that
might not have happened.
And then you do get release of stuff
that none of us thinks should be
released.
That's the terrible problem.
It doesn't seem like leaks are not just
inevitable now,
but it's baked into the pie that baked
into it.
It seems like there's almost no way to
keep stuff secret now operative at the
Democratic and Republican parties.
How much would you want to bake it into
the cake that you try to see that
there'll be a leak against your
opponents before the next election?
How much does that now become a part of
your strategize?
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
I'll put out a little stuff that I
hacked on the DNC kind of attitude,
you know,
or whatever.
I mean listen,
and if and if the Russians are,
you know,
Vladimir Putin said that,
what's the problem?
Shouldn't we just look,
the American people should know this
stuff.
So we released this information or
somebody releases this information,
but if they only release information on
one side,
have they influenced the election?
Right.
So you have to be careful how that works
too.
They have the ability to sort of set the
tone of the discussion.
Yeah.
I wonder what if they checked the
Republicans,
if they checked like what kinds of crazy
shit was said when they realize that
Donald Trump was running away with it,
heard something that there'd been a hack
and I,
and it was like new news,
so I'm not up to speed,
but that there had been at the RNC to.
Did you see everybody's freaking out now
over the fact.
And again we have to make the disclaimer
that the Russian hackers or whomever I
had this Russian hackers would get mad
at me when I say that.
Whomever it was that did this,
that they've been known to alter stuff.
So you have to take it all with a grain
of salt,
but,
but what came out,
I guess was a list,
and this is from the Democratic Party's
main list of donors,
right?
Their internal documents which shows the
top donors how much they gave,
and then what was given in return,
Basadur ships,
director of homeland security,
all that kind of stuff.
Now here's the funky part that says old
almost as the republic.
It was called the spoil system in the
early 18 hundreds,
right?
I win election.
So all my buddies get jobs,
right?
Everybody who supported me.
So there've been asked though,
ever since then,
the hatch act was one where they tried
to limit that and both parties act like
they don't do it anymore.
So when it comes out that they still do,
people freak out.
But here's the truth.
If the Democrats do it,
I'm sure the Republicans do it too.
I'd love to see a list from the last
Republican administration who their top
donors were.
All you have to do is look at who the
ambassadors were and especially the
ambassadors to good places,
right?
Who is the ambassador to Bermuda who was
the ambassador to London?
The UK one is always a coveted position.
How much did that guy give and because
it's always been the way it is.
There's a part of me that goes,
Eh,
what are you going to do?
But the other part of me goes,
that's the corruption you wish more
Americans knew was built into the
system.
Right?
If you found out that the guy who's in
charge of making sure this country safe
and the Homeland Security Department got
the job because he gave money to get the
job,
how much less safer we than if you gave
it to the most qualified candidate.
That's a very important point.
And how many people are doing it for
vanity positions just so they can say
they are that ambassador.
Yeah.
London.
I just saw a way to reform joe,
so all we have to do is get some really
rich marijuana grower to give them
enough money so that he becomes the
Department of Homeland Security Director
and you could get that corruption thing
working in your favor.
That's actually possible with the amount
of money that I'm making in Colorado.
You never know.
You would never direct your homeland
security made all of his money growing
weed and it comes full circle.
How much have you
paid attention to?
All the controversy about the Clinton
Foundation.
I have a special relationship with the
Clintons.
You know,
I was in talk radio during that whole
administration and there they're
relatively unique people as a couple and
they're very hard to describe and I
always try to be fair.
You know,
I'm,
I'm very into fair and seeing context,
but let's be honest.
These are two people that,
you know,
here's the way I look at it.
If you're Hillary Clinton and they have
been after you since before your husband
was president,
you know,
in Arkansas,
they were after them,
right?
So you know how on you they're going to
be.
Wouldn't you stay so far away from any
lines that nobody could ever come close
to saying you were?
But they don't.
They both walk and straddle and that,
you know,
if you talked to people in Arkansas,
they just say that's the Clintons.
They,
they walk the straddle the line and a
lot of times they go in too much of one.
And why would you do that?
We talked about this with Anthony
Wiener,
you and I a long time ago.
If you know that stuff's out there,
why would you go and run for office
again?
It's the same thing with Clinton.
If you know you're the most watched man
in the world,
why on earth would you have an affair
with a teenage intern who you know will
not stay quiet about it?
It,
it,
it boggles the mind.
So if you're Hillary Clinton and you've
got everyone trying to come up with dirt
on you,
why would you do anything that was even
suspicious and yet they still walk that
line.
I don't get it.
Well,
don't you think?
I think
that first of all,
their patterns and their behavior and
their attitudes towards things were
established in the 19 eighties when the
world was a much simpler place.
And you can get away with what happened
in Mena,
Arkansas with all that craziness,
with,
you know,
the dropping drugs out of airplanes.
And uh,
when,
when you know,
which is all part of that narco series,
narco series,
I mean,
somebody was in on it.
I mean that guy who got shot and killed,
who is about to testify
for George Bush?
What the fuck was his name?
I'm convinced.
No,
no,
no.
The,
the pilot.
That was the drug pilot.
I remember the story of.
Dammit.
I can't remember the story though.
Yeah.
So client assessment I into this,
obviously some people knew about this.
Obviously the CIA was involved.
This guy was involved with some cowboys
and the CIA.
They were bringing drugs in from what
they were doing that during the Iran
contra thing in the 80.
So it's not old news.
Yeah,
no,
it's so somehow or another that was
standard operational procedure at least
on some level,
whether it's rogue,
rogue agents and the CIA or rogue people
in the government or whoever was
profiting on it.
And that was also of course,
what was,
what was going on in south central Los
Angeles during the contrast in the
center versus the Sandinista.
There was a relationship that they were
making money by selling drugs in the
ghetto and they were taking that money
and it was directly affecting global
politics in a country that cared about
reform.
How many of those things have to happen
before somebody would turn around and
say,
okay,
we have a big problem and we have to
weed that problem,
so out of the CIA or whichever agency
you want to,
you want a name so that it doesn't
happen again.
When that doesn't happen,
know I remember I'm looking into police
departments that had problems and in La
when I was growing up,
you knew which ones to avoid.
For example,
there was one in Signal Hill and we all
knew you don't.
You don't want to get pulled over there.
So eventually they had to disband the
whole police department and start from
scratch because every time they tried to
reform it,
there was a culture in that little
police department that absorbed new
members and the people that wouldn't
become part of the culture ended up
transferring out or whatever.
And the people that worked with the
culture state.
That's a microcosm of how all these
giant agencies work where,
how do you change the culture of
something when you would have to get rid
of the people who are there now who all
bought in or they wouldn't still be
there.
You know,
you were saying about the mainframe
computer.
If you wanted to start the CIA over
today,
would you use any of the people that are
in it now?
It's hard to know because I think if you
didn't,
you'd end up with an agency that
thought,
listen,
we're keeping America safe and if we
have to dose people with Lsd as happened
in the late fifties,
early 19 sixties as a way to make sure
that our people aren't dosed with Lsd,
we're going to do it.
You know the pilot was barry seal's.
I was trying to remember it.
So you're having the same problem by
him.
A little bit too many goddamn people.
Too much stuff in our brain.
Too much data.
But the.
So the Clintons in the 19 eighties,
they pretty much were able to get away
with pretty much whatever they wanted.
I mean,
they had so much immense power,
right.
She's Arkansas,
governor of Arkansas.
Yeah,
but he was a frequent freaks,
right.
It was just whipping his dick out all
over the place.
But what's funny is not exactly a
pipeline to the White House either.
So in that sense it was.
It was a little like getting somebody
from,
you know,
Mississippi as your president.
It's just a little different.
Well,
yeah.
No,
no doubt,
no doubt whatsoever,
but this time when all this stuff was
going on,
established their behavior patterns
maybe and then will mean Arkansas of
course is where the CIA was dropped or
someone in the CIA,
some rogue agent.
I don't think it was like a systemic
thing inside the CIA where the top of
the CIA was aware of it and condoned it
and sanctioned in with someone was
bringing in drugs and they bring it in
drugs to Arkansas.
I don't think it's a coincidence that
the fucking governor of Arkansas gets
fast track to becoming the president.
It's probably in some way related in
some some fiber,
whether it's.
I don't think it's the most important
aspect of his governorship,
but there's some connection there.
It has to be.
I'll tell you what though,
if you go look at Bill Clinton in the
primaries when he was basically chosen
to be the Democratic candidate to run
against the elder George Bush,
and you look at those stiffs he was up
against.
Yeah.
It's how it always is.
I mean,
when you look and you go,
okay,
there's a bunch of people who I could
never vote for 2 million years and
there's one person who's got some
charisma.
Right?
I don't know how it happens that way.
I mean,
if somebody wanted to say,
well,
that's the part that's rigged.
Listen to the two parties who are
private entities that can do whatever
they want.
Someone said to me the other day,
what happens if Hillary Clinton drops
out for health reasons?
You know who,
who naturally does the job devolve to,
and I said,
whoever the Democratic National
Committee wants it too,
which is really fascinating.
When I was a registered Democrat,
they make themselves out to be like a
constitutional,
a pillar of ours.
They're not.
They're a private entity that can do
what they want and they will do whatever
they want if they have to have that
comes down to it.
So all the people that voted in the
primaries for hilary or Bernie or it
doesn't mean anything anymore.
So now who are you being represented by
the king.
Just choose someone.
I mean,
this is what you're down to.
You're down to like a monarchy.
Well you said the funding,
you've talked about the founding fathers
earlier and I'm always blown away that
Madison,
who's the guy who's most responsible for
writing the constitution was like 23.
I was the most irresponsible,
you know,
goof off in the world I think at 23.
So you look at those guys and you
realize how much they had a problem with
what they called factions there version
of factions is what we would call
parties today.
And they thought it was poisonous and
yet it was like a generation later.
And what did they have cropping up
factions.
So it's,
it would be a really difficult thing.
It must be an evolutionary natural thing
to normally develop in a society like
ours,
but if you decided that that was the
poison pill,
what could you write into the founding
documents that prevented that?
I don't know,
but,
but to me that's the root of so much of
our evil in this country is we have two
parties that control a corrupt system
and in order to fix the corrupt system,
the two parties would have to be on
board to do it.
Well,
okay.
That's,
that's actually asking what if we said
the Fox to redesign the chicken coop?
It's the Fox is interest.
Well,
it's also what we were talking about,
whether it's the CIA or the NSA,
if you're them to redesign this thing,
you're asking relinquished some pants.
Right.
And to redesign it away where they can't
get back into it.
Even if they had to do it to save us.
I mean that's when it gets really wiggy.
If you say,
I don't want you spying on us anymore
and the next nine slash 11 attack,
we have happened because they couldn't
spot on us.
You better believe they'll point that
out.
Yeah,
and also if you had to redesign it,
you would have to eliminate some jobs.
I mean there's no way this thing is
operating at 100 percent efficiency.
So if somebody really audited it,
whether it's the CIA or the FBI or the
NSA,
I mean do 100 percent sure they're doing
their best,
but there's no way it's done really
well.
It's just the government,
the government fucks up almost
everything because most people don't
want to work for the government.
So who do you get?
You got a bunch of people that,
well,
okay,
I'll do that job.
It's like,
is anybody clamoring to be the guy at
the NSA that gets to read Dan Carlin's
email?
I think I,
I think what it is,
I'm in a better way to put it as it's
the systems decline.
I mean it just deteriorates over time
and it's,
it's.
Every system is remarkably hard to go
back and fix and the government,
especially as you know,
we've got 240 years of,
of deadwood and you don't often go in
there and have a spring cleaning
session.
You know,
and I think the founding fathers were
people who were aware,
they used to talk about lifespans of
countries and so you know that computer
analogy we use as a pretty good one.
This is an old computer that we've
patched many,
many times and also tasked to do many,
many more things in the constitution
ever envisioned because you have a great
depression or you have a second world
war or you have nuclear weapons appear
on the scene,
so all of a sudden we have a flexible
constitution to deal with unforseeables
as you pointed out.
Okay.
But how flexible is it?
I mean at what point have you stretched
it so far that it's become a fig leaf?
I try to remind people.
We did a whole series on the decline and
fall of the Roman republic and what a
lot of people don't know is that when
the Roman Empire first appeared in for a
long time afterwards,
they kept all the forms.
Senators were still elected.
I mean,
you have an all powerful emperor,
but they still went through the process
of electing senators as though nothing
had changed.
They still held elections,
they still had people giving money to
senators to give them favors,
but we had a system in Rome as if I was
there,
but at that point it was a total
dictatorship,
but we elected senators anyway because
the forms had a long and noble tradition
that was tied to the way Roman saw
themselves the same way.
We're tied to that 19 fifties high
school textbook of who we are.
If we had a dictator someday,
they would never be able to get rid of
senators and because the forms are very
important.
Well,
that's one of the biggest fears about
the Patriot Act.
The Patriot Act two as well,
is that if something did happen in
martial law was declared,
would we really have the same system
that we think we have when we have that
19 fifties textbook version of,
or would we really have a military
dictatorship that's disguised?
I just read a book,
I think it was called American coup.
You know back 20 years ago,
people who wrote those books were
conspiracy people who had no real.
Now the people writing those books are
all insiders and they have
generals writing blurbs on the back and
this guy,
it's kind of a boring book because he
talks so much about fema and Katrina and
all these things,
but sometimes when you're diagramming
how these things happen,
it's not spy thriller type stuff.
It's really sometimes run of the mill.
We had this problem.
We had.
His point is that we've been living in a
society that's operating between the
lines in the constitution for 50 years
now and that the government is
absolutely petrified about all the
threats out there to us and in order to
protect us.
Things like little writings on hemp
paper from 240 years ago are not going
to stand in the way of us protecting us
from another nine slash 11 or a nuclear
bomb going off in a harbor or something
like that.
When of course,
the argument to that is like,
of course you're going to say you're
protecting us.
Of course that's sometimes you are.
Sometimes you're not,
but how convenient is that?
You are also controlling
vast amounts of wealth,
controlling so much of the ability of
the United States citizens to to do
their jobs,
to get through life,
to,
to do anything they want to do without
being infringed on by this group of
people that sort of got elected,
got elected in some sort of a weird,
strange way in an antiquated system that
doesn't really make any sense anymore
and there's only really held accountable
up to a certain extent.
That's one of the weirder aspects about
real government corruption because the
real corruption as the legal shit like
you're talking about the ledger,
showing what people did,
what and what they received for those
donations and how much they gave and how
much they got out of it and how they
became like that is how is that legal in
insider trading is illegal.
How is that legal?
And Martha Quinn goes to jail,
not Martha Quinn.
She went,
yeah,
the MTC zero j from MTV.
Martha Stewart rather goes to jail for a
stock trade.
You know,
where she was not honest about the
information that she knew about
profiting off of stocks rate.
It's,
it's insane,
like the disparity.
It's insane how much,
how much weird corruption is just
entangled into the system that the only
way to get rid of what would have to be
you would have to stop all those jobs
that are,
that evolve around all that money coming
in and you're dealing with untold
millions of dollars and that it's being
siphoned from the system by all these
people,
the lobbyists and all the special
interest groups that constantly work in
the Washington hive to extract those
people.
At this point,
it's almost impossible without a total
reset of the system.
Well,
I look at how.
Look at how things changed.
So for example,
when the founding fathers set up war
powers,
which they understood to be the most
important thing,
they separated the part where we decide
to go to war from the power of fighting
the war,
and they gave the power to fight the war
to the president.
He's the commander in chief,
but they did not give him the power to
decide to go to war.
Right?
That's too much power for one guy.
They gave that to Congress.
So Congress has the power to declare war
once they do.
The president has really extreme
emergency authority to fight the war.
When Harry Truman took us into Korea in
1950,
he called it a police action and he
called it a police action because you
don't need to declare a war to have a
police action,
but he sent the united.
I mean we lost 50,000
guys or something in Korea.
Um,
and you know,
a lot more Koreans.
Um,
once you do that,
we've never declared war again.
As a matter of fact,
no president even throws that out there,
that they would love to have a support,
a declaration of support by Congress.
But once you do that,
you,
you break an important wall,
the wall that says that the president
has basically unlimited powers and more
time and now he has the right to decide
when war time is okay.
That's a firewall that had been built
into the system that once it's broken,
you can never repair that.
You can never go back.
Congress has no way to repair that
firewall.
So now somebody said to me,
if donald trump's elected president,
can he use a nuclear bomb against a
country or could he decide I'm going to
scare the heck out of North Korea and
I'm going to know drop a bomb off their
coast?
Yes,
and he can do it without asking anybody
and the only people that might tell him
no.
Are the military and the military starts
telling the president,
no,
that's almost as scary as a president
that can drop a nuclear bomb whenever he
wants to.
So that's in the.
In the founder's construction of the
country.
In in their mind,
you would have had to have gone to
Congress and say,
can we drop a nuclear bomb on North
Korea?
And then Congress would have voted
decided and then the president would
have been empowered to take whatever
measures are necessary.
Right?
We've that firewall is gone.
The president has extreme emergency
authority in foreign policy.
Now he didn't have to ask Congress for
anything.
There's only one thing congress can do.
They have the power of the purse so they
can cut off the funds,
but can you imagine our troops say in
Iraq or Afghanistan and the congress
doesn't want them there anymore,
so the choice they have is to stop
sending a meals and replacement bullets
and it's not going to happen.
So those are the ways that the
constitution gets destroyed.
And Truman,
I mean,
you look at what we mentioned earlier,
the CIA,
the NSA,
that power truman did more damage to
this country and in,
in one presidency than anyone I can
think of.
And,
and,
and yet I cut him some slack because he
did.
The world had never existed.
It existed in his heart.
He had a whole new challenges to deal
with.
It's like when Obama came into office
and promised to undo the extremes of the
previous administration,
had he done that,
we could have said,
okay,
nine slash 11 happened.
We freaked out.
And then we fixed it,
right?
We,
we got our balance back.
By not doing that,
he caught a fight it.
Now that's the rule,
right?
When both parties agree on something,
it becomes the way we do things now.
So if Truman had left office and
Eisenhower had come in as a member of
the other party and
said,
Whoa,
the CIA thing is more like an American
Gestapo,
we're going to get rid of it.
Boom.
Truman is a blip.
But when he decides to embrace the CIA,
now that's the way we do business.
So if the two parties don't sort of look
out for each other and say,
listen,
nine slash 11 is a one off,
strange experience,
okay,
we understand how somebody could
overreact and freak out.
We'll fix it and instead say,
no,
we'll keep things the way they are.
Then you take it another step down.
Another firewall has been broken in.
The constitution has been stretched
again,
to the point where there were big holes
and now is there a fourth amendment
anymore really mean there's amendments
of the constitution and people will say
to me all the time,
Dan,
you say our freedoms going away.
Tell me when we repealed in amendment
doesn't work that way.
Rome didn't do that,
right?
They kept the senators,
the forms stay,
but the reality can be changed mightily.
Right?
Yeah,
and it seems like once it's changed,
you know,
what is that old saying about a power
loss never recovered.
It's exactly where,
and let's understand something,
let's,
let's not take the American people off
the blame list.
If another nine slash 11 happens,
they're going to go and call for the
heads of the people that voted against
spying on,
you know,
I mean that's how we are.
We're such a panicky people that were
not willing to suck up a lot of
casualties if,
if that's what's required to defend some
of this stuff.
If you're going to say you can't spy on
Americans,
just understand some nasty Americans are
going to get fertilizer bombs and blow
up stuff sometimes because they slipped
through that protection for you and me
and everyone else.
Yeah.
I wonder if over time,
like going back to that battleship
analogy,
like that's going to be the only thing
that clears this up is that the people
that started getting elected into office
deal with the new level of transparency
and the people that are growing up now
who will eventually become politicians.
They grow up in a different world and so
their view of what's possible and not
possible is very different than like we
were talking about the Clintons who kind
of had an open pass to kind of do a lot
of shit that they wanted to do back in
the 19 eighties and the nineties and
they're still kind of operating like
when you're talking about Hillary
Clinton and the Clintons just kind of
doing their thing and it's like if you
look at the difference between here's.
This is not a conspiracy theory.
If you look at the difference between
what Hillary Clinton says,
the FBI found out about her emails
versus what the FBI says about what they
found out about Hillary Clinton's
emails.
Someone's lying and I don't think it's
the FBI.
Someone's lying.
Like her version of it is a lie.
It's just not real.
Like what she's saying is not what
they're saying.
What's the assumption built into that
though?
The assumption is that I know that
that's not the real spin that the FBI
director put on it and the five percent
of Americans who read newspapers know
that that's not the spin,
but the majority of people that I'm
trying to reach will simply hear what I
say and if they want to know.
And here's the thing.
I mean this is like a.
We all have.
If
you want to support that candidate
anyway,
you're inclined to believe what they say
and disinclined to believe what the
other guy says.
This is part of the problem about the
binary,
lesser of two evils thing we get into
because Hillary Clinton is one of the
most unpopular candidates.
I mean,
I always tell,
you know,
I have two daughters and they constantly
asked me these really uncomfortable
questions about why don't we have women
presidents and all this kind of stuff.
So I'm all in favor of that.
And I have a lot of women who say,
you know,
Hillary Clinton's,
uh,
the most qualified candidate we've ever
had for high offices is all just sexism.
And what I try to tell them is,
is this really the person you want to be
the poster child though,
as the first woman president?
Because I'll tell you what,
if current trends continue,
I don't imagine Republicans are going to
lay up on her at all,
right?
The whole,
the entire Clinton administration was
the Republicans trying to get them for
something.
So imagine she gets elected.
Imagine that they continue to hound her
the way they do and remembering that
they tend to walk that line,
right?
Being the Clintons,
there's going to be 90 percent of
nothing in their travel gates at Rose
Hill law firms,
but there's going to be something they
find eventually they will impeach her
for that.
And if she's the first woman president
to be impeached,
how does that help you as the,
you know,
if the first African American president
had been impeached,
that wouldn't look very good.
Right?
And I got to say President Obama,
you know,
I don't like a lot of stuff he's done,
but from a scandal standpoint,
he'd been pretty good.
You know,
by if you grade these people on the
curve,
his scandal record's been pretty good.
If you don't count accidental deaths and
drones,
that's not a scandal.
That standard operating procedure.
That is,
that's how we do.
That's foreign policy baby.
That's,
that's not a a bug,
that's a feature.
But it seems like a scandal when people
find out the numbers of innocent people
killed by drones and how many have.
And also the,
the real issues with him saying that he
was gonna support whistleblowers.
Oh yeah.
And what they've actually done with and
blowers and how hard they've been on the
freedom of the press has been a very,
very confusing time for a lot of people
that were Obama supporters eight years
ago.
And thought like,
I did that.
This was the answer.
Like finally we have the super
articulate young guy who has a view of
the world that's similar to us.
You know,
he said all the right things when he ran
for office.
And but,
but again,
what he had said was,
we're going to go and overturn the
mistakes of the previous administration.
Had he done that,
he would have reestablished a few
firewalls that we ripped apart.
It's always interesting to try to
theorize why that didn't happen.
People love to tell you those stories.
Oh,
they took him in the back room and they
showed him the Kennedy assassination.
Said any questions?
That's a Bill Hicks bit,
but you don't know.
Part of you can say,
listen,
they took him in the back room and said,
here are the threats.
We stopped last month.
Do you really want to do what you say?
You know you don't,
but you would love the president to at
least say,
okay,
I'm going to hold a televised press
conference now and I'm going to say,
here is what I said when I ran for
president.
Here's why I can't do it right when they
don't though.
Yeah,
but what was going to say when they
don't do that,
you open up the door to what the hell's
going on.
He gave you this small promise and that
small promise and maybe a healthcare
reform,
but he said he was going to essentially
repair
the constitution and he didn't.
So what's the story?
Why?
Yeah,
it's,
it's just so hard to guess and he's not
going to tell you.
So it's one of those things that we're
just gonna all have to debate about to
the end of time and then go home.
Angry.
Well,
as everyone says,
the what happens when you get the truly,
truly without limits candidate into
office without those firewalls.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's one thing to say,
listen to the president can drop a
nuclear bomb on anybody wants to
legally.
It's another thing to have a president
who says,
you know,
I can drop a nuclear bomb.
I'll just,
you know,
we'll do that.
It's also hard to understand like when
you've seen a guy like trump,
I don't want to get back to the Clinton
Foundation before I forget,
but while were you seeing a guy like
trump and you listened to the people
that have actually interviewed him or
talked to him and have conversations
with him?
Like one of them was,
I forget what,
head of military that he was discussing
this with what he was talking about,
the nuclear option.
You can't,
we just use nuclear weapons.
That line.
Yeah.
Do you,
you heard about that,
right?
And you wonder like what was the tone of
that discussion?
You know,
like,
like we're just being curious versus.
Yeah,
well,
or was he being silly?
You know what I mean?
Maybe look,
he's Donald Trump,
right?
He's a charmer.
So he's this public figure.
He meets people,
he talks to them.
He puts on this persona.
Obviously a lot of this stuff he says in
a lot of ways he's like a comedian
because he's saying so many things for
effect and whether or not he believes it
or not is not the point.
The point is they're going to get a big
impact.
He's going to kill,
you know,
like.
So I told the president of Mexico,
the wall just got 10 foot higher.
He's doing stuff like that.
He's doing lines.
Those are punchlines,
right?
It might not be that funny,
but it's got it's a punch and he's
saying those in weird places,
like he's saying like it's,
it's part of what makes him interesting
is that he's like this weird entertainer
that's hijack the system.
And I say interesting.
It's like a very generous use of the
word.
Um,
it's,
it's scary.
But what interests be though we should
get these.
It's funny because,
you know,
on twitter,
some of the trump supporters,
and I don't ever want a broad brush
because I know a lot of people that are
going to vote for trump that are old
people that are,
find people that are,
you know,
but there's certainly a,
an,
an edge on some of those people that
support them,
that,
that has certain racism,
all kinds of things.
We see them on twitter.
And so,
you know,
when,
when one of them was talking about,
um,
you know,
how Donald Trump is this,
they conservative is one of the words
they like to use.
Now you know,
all those kinds of this.
But,
but to me,
no American who understands the United
States well would want to vote for some
strong man.
That whole attitude of wanting some
strong man figure is unamerican is I can
think of.
And if you go study your,
your Roman republic history,
it was the strong men riding in on a
white horse that really signaled the
beginning of the end.
You know,
don't,
don't anyone who wants too much power
and promises to use it to.
That's somebody to be afraid of in my
book
anyway.
No,
it's definitely not a measured person.
I do not want some strong man.
Well this is things that he says that
you know,
that he's just trying to get a reaction.
Like what,
what did he say about Mccain as that he,
he likes people that didn't get caught.
I know like,
what the fuck are you saying?
When he was basically a guy who get five
deferments or whatever it had that's a,
you know,
he'll say,
well what else does that?
But it's also what he does.
He says those outrageous things.
He hits those punches.
Will someone's raping him,
you know he's got like these punchlines
was up against on the primary stage with
a bunch of stiff robotic people
repeating talking points.
It was a little like Clinton wasn't his
primary is in,
in,
in the early nineties when when it's a
bunch of deadbeats,
stiff cardboard cutout pretend figures
and one person that you don't know what
they're going to say next and that
becomes interesting.
But what's interesting is the
charismatic type people that we are so
attracted to really are not what you
want as a leader.
You don't want that person that needs so
much attention that they polish their
persona to a point where they're
incredibly influential because a lot of
that persona,
a lot of that when you're seeing is it's
like they're entertainers.
I mean that's what it is.
When you're a really charismatic person,
you've figured out a way to speak in a
way that people like you more and then
you've.
You've exercised that to the point where
it's a well honed muscle with incredible
endurance and you have a great
sensitivity to how people are perceiving
you so you know how to come across as
noble and patriotic and brilliant and
you know,
we all know that some of the things that
people say like standard things that
people say,
there's some of them that you really
shouldn't even be able to say anymore
because it doesn't mean anything and
shouldn't be allowed to just hijack
those words and just use it to gain
merit.
Like God bless our troops.
I don't know what the fuck do you mean?
What do you mean by the national anthem?
When people freak out over that,
I always say,
listen,
I'd be nice if we freaked out a little
bit about what these songs and flags and
symbols represent instead of freaking
out over the symbol and ignoring the
stuff.
Exactly.
Well,
I'll tell you when we're talking about a
person who's an incredible position of
influence and they're saying these
things that are kind of not like a real
sentence.
It's not really what you thought.
You just knew that other people have
said that it's something you say,
so you're saying it,
but you're saying it about a very
important thing.
You're saying about the young people,
the children,
of all the people that are here,
the 18 year old kids that are sent over
there to shoot people they've never met
and you're saying,
God bless those people.
Who is.
What is God?
Are you saying the invisible man in the
sky with the harp?
Is that who you're.
So you're saying God bless our kids to
go kill other people's kids?
Are you sure that that's how you want to
say that?
Like you just wanted to have this open
statement,
God bless our troops to do I want our
troops to be safe?
Of course do what do I wish that we
didn't have to use them?
We didn't have to have.
Absolutely.
It's not a.
not a negative in any way,
shape or form towards the military,
but it's these expressions that leaders
are just.
They are freely to plug into.
It's like a happy birthday to you or
like a weird like youtube.
You're dealing with massive issues that
are super,
like not just charged,
but the consequences of being wrong or
right,
or being unsuccessful or massive to just
gigantic.
You mentioned something I,
I've always found very interesting,
which is,
which is the charisma of the individual.
I had a,
uh,
a poly sci professor back in college who
happened to be a German guy,
so he was sort of viewing our system
from outside our system.
And he said,
you know,
this is how I used to take such a
problem with you Americans,
is you have a president that combines
two jobs.
If you were a European country,
that would be two jobs.
One is the bean counter guy,
the one you were mentioning how you want
to be president,
the one that you know,
he's maybe not so great at the big
speeches and you don't want that guy
going to the funerals and representing
America.
And he goes.
And then we have in Europe,
chancellors or presidents that these
people physically represent the soul.
They go to the funerals.
So he said,
you want John Wayne to be that guy and
then you want some bean counter to be
the other guy,
but in your country you require both of
those things in the same person.
He says,
do you know how often you get John Wayne
who is also a bean counter?
He goes,
that's your problem.
you end up usually electing the John
Wayne and wishing you had a bean
counter.
So I mean in Europe.
He said,
those are two separate jobs.
It's a good point.
What I was getting at by the expressions
is like saying things like,
God bless the troops or God bless
America.
Is that just the whole way of talking as
a politician is so it's so false and so
accepted that we know that they're going
to stand in front of all these people
with this preplanned out speech that is
like this weird rally,
this weird artificial strip club,
Dj voice that they put on.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
but this is why trump was so even to me
attractive early on because he exposed
what happened to Rubio was a perfect
example.
If you remember the primary debates with
trump and rubio,
rubio kept repeating the talking points,
so then Christy among other people said,
that's a talking point and you keep
saying it and then he said it again two
more times.
Almost proving that this is all scripted
to the fun part of Donald Trump.
Earlier on.
Was he exposed all of that is you
sometimes get the feeling that he didn't
prep it all right.
I mean there was.
You didn't know what he was going to
say.
I loved trying to imagine the dilemma.
You know before these debates,
they always have someone stand in for
the other candidate.
Who Do you get to stand in for trump if
you're like when Hillary Clinton
practicing her debates who sits there
and because I mean because you don't
know median or something,
but the point is is that,
is that that was the fun.
He exposed kind of the,
the,
the artificial Kabuki theater sort of
way.
This has developed and I liked that
because I think it's good when more
Americans see what it really is,
right?
In other words,
most of the time you're right.
They either get fooled by that or
they've heard it so many times they
don't even pay attention.
Trump helped expose that.
So in that sense,
that was good for the system.
Of course,
now we've gone quite a bit farther down
that road and uh,
and I don't think it is so good for the
system anymore.
I do think anybody who would beat
Hillary Clinton almost.
I mean,
I think,
you know,
Democrats keeps saying to me,
if you don't vote for Hillary Clinton,
you're going to put trump in office and
that'll be your fault.
And I keep saying it's not my fault.
You put Hillary Clinton up as your
candidate.
I mean,
in 2008,
we saw how unpopular she was.
She shouldn't have lost a Barack Obama.
She was going to be correlated.
Then you realize if she hadn't had a 70
something year old democratic socialists
who,
let's be honest,
does not have a ton of charisma and a
guy.
Nobody's ever heard from her.
Only two primary challengers up on that
stage.
She wouldn't be here if Joe Biden and
it's the first time I can think of that.
A vice president hasn't tried to run
him.
If Joe Biden had run,
he would be up against trump now and I
don't think trump would stand a chance
to be honest,
and I don't like Joe Biden,
but I just think he's a zero and right
now trump is a negative running against
Hillary who's a negative zero kicks.
Both their rear end.
Yeah,
and he's also a zero who's had no
negative consequences of eight years in
office,
really?
Which is amazing because he's known for
gaffes.
Yeah,
he's a goofy dude.
Well,
we used to have this thing in Boston and
stitches comedy club.
We'd call it Joe Biden tonight.
This was 1988 malarkey.
He's an Irish guy.
Would steal other people's material.
That's what you would do like I feel.
Yeah,
because people don't know,
but biden plagiarize Kennedy's speeches
when he was running for president and
was a big deal.
I recall everybody's Kinda forgot about
that,
but he lived,
literally just stole giant passages out
of.
That's something we look back on now and
go,
ah,
the good old days when that was the only
thing we could slam somebody for.
Well,
they're still doing it like didn't
Mellinia or how did he say?
Or she stole a.
She claimed she didn't,
but it's a remarkable coincidence.
Well,
it's Michelle Obama's exact words,
isn't it?
So what are the odds?
She didn't write that shit anyway.
Somebody I wouldn't be surprised and
someone brought this up and it wasn't
me,
but someone suggested it and I think
they're probably right that trump did it
on purpose and plagiarized Michelle
Obama speech so that people would talk
about it so it would give even more
attention to his campaign.
I love that.
Trump questions like Michael Moore of
all people came out with a piece about
three weeks ago and he started the piece
off by saying something to the effect
of,
you don't have to believe what I'm about
to tell you,
but I will tell you that I have spoken
to people who are in the know who tell
me that trump doesn't even want this
gate,
that this is something that has gotten
out of control,
that this was more of a,
I'll get a TV series afterwards and then
he didn't expect you to do this,
and I thought to myself,
okay,
I don't know that I believe that,
but if that's true,
this is the most unusual,
funky,
weird American political history story
I've ever heard.
I think it's the last gasps of a dying
empire.
I just don't think you can continue the
way they've been doing it.
I think this is showing us that there
are no good representatives.
There's,
there's no good candidates.
There's no way.
We didn't know about them.
If they were there,
they would know about them.
I mean,
maybe there's some young
that are coming up and there's some
young congress people that are coming up
maybe.
Well this was in Lawrence lessig spoke
book,
a republic loss,
which by the way,
if anyone wants to go check out,
he put it on the Internet for free now
so you can read it.
And one was the Harvard maybe.
Um,
so,
but one of the things he said in that it
was so interesting because he showed how
people who are getting started,
you know,
running for mayor,
the low level things,
how the parties begin the weeding out
process.
And the first thing that they want to
know is how good are you at raising
money?
And this determines whether or not the
party,
let's this mayoral candidate put the Rod
after their name or that may oral
cancer.
So in other words,
from the very beginning,
one of the main qualifications is how
good are you at raising money?
Okay?
So fast forward to when that guy or
woman is up on the stage running for
president.
And then they have four other elected
positions leading up to that.
All of which require you to be a better
fundraiser when that's one of the number
one qualifications required for the
parties to let you progress.
Then what do you end up with at the end
of the line?
Mean what are the carrots and sticks
that they're looking for?
A little bit different than maybe what
you and I as voters are looking for.
That's why trump is such a weird one,
right?
Because he's a guy who has so much
money.
He funded allegedly,
allegedly.
People like that.
He obviously has money credit.
He got really good credit.
I mean he gets sell some of his shit and
he would have money.
He owned some of that stuff.
It seems like it does have a lot of
stuff and maybe as money is wrapped up
in a lot of that stuff.
I guess.
I don't know.
I'd like to stop voting for 70 year old
people and it's not an age is kind of
thing,
but as a person who just mentioned to
you that at 50 I'm starting to forget
things.
I can only imagine what I'll be like in
20 years.
Well,
I said that about Hillary Clinton and
people call me sexist.
They were like that sex.
I'm like,
she's an old lady.
Trump is.
He's an old man.
That's right.
If you could watch those TV shows from
like the 19 fifties and you see their
portrayal of a 70 year old sitting on
the porch falling asleep and widdling.
That's what this is.
Seventy may be the new 60,
but 68 grade either.
Well,
it's definitely not the prime of your
cognitive abilities.
It's not the primary.
This level may be good,
but your bas speed is terrible.
Yeah.
There you go.
Again,
with the bus that trump trump,
I mean doesn't even have experience,
so it's even more bizarre.
So it's not like you're dealing with
this elderly statesman that has so much
knowledge and so much so much invested
in our system of government and really
believes in it so much that he wants to
lead this country and make America great
again.
Now you've got a super rich guy who's
famous for going,
you're fired.
And when trump supporters say,
well,
he'll pick the best people.
I always want to point out,
you know,
he's already shown some of the people
that he likes and there's the same old
group of people you had before,
but he's not going and picking other
business people who've now he goes and
finds this and you're going,
okay,
it's the same group,
so I get Donald Trump presiding over the
same old group of people who've been
wrong about everything so far.
I mean that's the problem is that how do
you get away from the people who are
consistently wrong in a merit system?
The people that should be promoted are
the ones who are right.
More often.
We don't get that.
We have the same faces forever for A.
I mean the same guys who are,
who are on,
I always say on if CNN is going to put
to just name one these experts to tell
us what this latest North Korean nuclear
missile thing,
these would you please put up their
track record the way you would put up
the wins and loss record of a manager in
baseball.
Do you want that manager who's who's
four and 72 explaining to you the world
series strategy,
or are you going to say,
this guy doesn't know Jack,
because if they put the records of these
people they have on the programs,
you'd look at it and go,
I'm not listening to this guy.
He's consistently wrong.
Yeah,
but once someone becomes someone that
people recognize in that regard,
you're an expert.
You're in the Rolodex a quote.
That's right.
It's just.
It's a weird time.
I think it is the weirdest time ever in
politics.
I don't think there's ever been anything
weirder than this.
Well,
let me show you what.
What bothers in independent like yours
truly.
If you look at the demographics of the
United States,
the independence or actually the last
poll I saw were a slight majority now,
so divide the pie into three Democrats,
Republicans and everybody else,
which is what the independents are
winning.
We're not a party.
We don't have a candidate we could agree
upon,
but we're everyone else where the king
makers in this election,
right?
Then you watch a TV and watch CNN or Fox
and they have 10,000
analysts talking about politics on there
on election night and everything else
and half of them are democratic
operators,
operatives and half a Republican
operatives.
Where the heck is anybody who could
speak for that giant slice of the pot
and you would think that that common
sense would dictate you would grab some
people,
right?
What our independence thinking.
Instead they asked Democrats and
Republicans and independents are
thinking,
and I'm not saying that because I have a
point.
I'm saying that because it confounds me,
get.
It seems pretty straightforward.
It seems like if CNN or any of these
news networks decided to help support
this independent idea and bring in
independence and and show that that
independence or the vast majority of the
voters are,
or the majority of the slight majority
of majority of the voters in America.
If they showed that and promoted that
idea and people that people would go,
wow,
I didn't know that.
Not that kind of reporting in on it like
that.
And I think they're complicit because
they have relationships with the people
that they know that where's the money,
the money is interviewing and getting on
camera.
The people that are the most popular
right now and most likely to win.
That's why one of the most amazing
things that trump did was all that shit
dog.
And he did talk about Mexicans being
rapists and all this nuts about the wall
and all the.
All the different crazy things that he
said when he did that,
the news was forced to cover him.
They were forced to.
They liked it as long as we were still
in the primary stage.
Yeah.
They thought there's no way this guy's
gonna win.
Everybody said that there's no way this
guy's gonna win.
Right?
I said that.
Yeah.
One of the people that said,
well,
he's now neck and neck with Hillary and
the national polls.
I will say this.
And,
and,
and didn't I just say you shouldn't
listen to people who have a bad track
record.
So I was wrong about that.
So bear that
in mind.
Oh,
and one on my trump analysis on how far
he'll go.
So just be fair.
Um,
but you know,
when you look at the American electoral
system,
like a,
an analyst does,
they notice important states.
You have to win,
right?
This state has to,
you know,
as Ohio goes or as Florida,
there's certain places,
and then there are other places that are
gimmes.
This state will always go blue.
This state will always go red.
So the battle ground are the,
are the states that are the toss ups in
a bunch of those states.
Hillary Clinton is leading.
And so the attitude that the sharpies at
least have is that it doesn't matter
what the polls look like,
it matters how Ohio goes and it matters
how Florida,
you know.
So in other words,
those are the choke points that the real
sharpies work from for you.
I mean,
when Hillary Clinton decides four years
ago,
I'm going to run for president,
okay,
get into Ohio now.
Start working those places now.
And so when people talk about trump not
having a robust establishment or
organization on the ground,
this is where he's going to get killed.
They'll kill him in those states and
then he may,
when you know,
you could conceivably come up with an
election where trump gets more actual
votes,
but Clinton wins the electoral college
and winds the key states and that's how
the sharpies who do this for a living
as,
as consultants and as campaign
strategist,
that's how they,
when they find those places,
I think when you see her fainting at
that nine slash 11 thing,
when they're trying to walk her to the
car and she starts bad timing on that,
huh?
All of a sudden drudge looks like a
nostradamus in that,
doesn't it?
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's terrible to see.
It's terrible to see that she's in such
poor health that she starts just falling
down.
I got to tell you though mean you know
you,
you could do it because you're in good
shape.
If I had tried to do what either one of
those two people had done in terms of
what their schedule has been like,
I would die 100 percent height and major
drinking problem.
I'd be drinking too much caffeine.
I've been drinking too much alcohol.
I'd be.
I'd take up smoking.
I don't know what I do,
but I mean what we require those people
to do with this permanent campaign that
goes on forever and these are 70 year
old people.
As we said.
I'm amazed they both haven't broken down
and if I'm trump I would look at this
and go,
do I really want this?
If this is how hard the job will be,
I could be in Hawaii.
I could be.
They do.
They all go gray.
What's going to happen?
Know trump is great,
let's be honest.
Right,
but how much is a 70 year old guy going
to age when he looks at how old the
presidents getting those jobs?
I think trump's going to sleep in.
He's going to hire people to do all the
dirty work.
He was just going to just get on the
Internet and go,
you're fired.
You have a youtube channel who knows,
you know,
that is a part of you that would love to
just have a view of what it,
you know,
like a Gilligan's island episode where
you have a dream sequence.
The coconut hits you on the head and you
imagine what I would,
you know,
I don't want to live through it,
but I'd love to see it for a minute to
see what it would look at.
Hillary Clinton will just be more of the
same.
That's the.
We're heading towards an iceberg here
and she's one of the people that set the
course.
So that's my problem with her.
She's,
she's doubling down on what always had.
Whereas trump is,
is the wild card.
I mean you just don't know.
Well,
like you said,
there's a lot of intelligent people that
support trump,
but man,
there's a lot of assholes that support
trump.
Lady that got punched in the face at a
trump rally.
Can you explain to me,
and I've talked about this in a couple
of shows.
Another thing that I'm having a bad
track record myself,
maybe you shouldn't listen to me at all,
but,
but on the racism thing,
which I don't,
I don't ever want to put a number on
what percentage of the trump supporters
fall into that category that we see
twitter people trolling us on,
but,
but I thought that was going the way of
the Dodo.
I am more surprised by that than
anything else that the rise in overt
and,
and I don't even want to say racism,
but just people who look at the world
with that,
that viewpoint,
that Lens.
I thought we were,
you know,
not evolving but,
but like I thought those people were
dying out.
I thought they were like,
right.
She bunkers and they were just going to
be.
And to see that recur is the biggest
surprise I've had in my adult lifetime.
I think when analyzing politics.
Well,
they absolutely still exist.
The question is have they diminished in
numbers?
I think they have,
but if you're just dealing with social
media,
there's so many voices.
So many people have a voice.
If you're dealing.
This is one of the ways that I've always
tried to describe how many retarded
people that are on the country,
and I don't mean people with down
syndrome.
I'm not.
I'm not going to not stop using that
word.
It's not a medical term.
It's doesn't mean people with the
disease.
It's almost fucking moron.
Okay,
okay.
If there's 300 million people in this
country,
one out of 100 is going to be a fucking
idiot.
At least 100.
Really,
really,
really nice.
Really Nice.
That's 3 million fucking idiots just in
this country that is a fucking gigantic.
Minneapolis size city,
twitter,
morons,
and tweet a lot and they could just be
racist and sexist or just trying to get
a rise out of us or only have a 10 year
old kids.
I mean,
that's the other thing.
Some of these are kids who think,
okay,
that most shocking thing I can say is
some racist term.
I'm not supposed to say.
Of course there's all the above because
young kids like I would have done when I
was 17,
if you gave me a computer when I was 17,
but I knew I could tweet to Al Gore.
I'd probably make the meanest fucking
tweet.
I would try to be funny.
Yeah.
You know,
I just think there's,
there's so many voices out there that
when you see racism attached to the
Donald Trump campaign and you know,
like you can't really say what
percentage of Donald Trump supporters or
is it more of a problem in the trump
campaign and the hillary campaign?
Yes.
Does the,
he does the fact that he won't take it
head on,
you know,
when they,
I was gonna say you can see the
reporters try to sort of frame the
questions so that he has to either go
left or go right on this,
you know,
uh,
would you,
would you denounce the KKK and David
Duke support?
What did he say?
I don't know what the KKK is or
something like that,
but he came up with some answer that.
Can you look that up?
Because I don't know.
I don't want to,
I don't know.
I'm going to get 10,000
angry.
He should go with the really easy stuff
like slavery.
Good or bad,
Donald,
it's
just real easy stuff.
Just give me your position on that.
Okay.
Let's work from their civil war.
Good idea.
Bad idea.
You know what?
Oh God.
I just had this moment outside of my
body where I thought we're really
talking about this stuff and you know,
that there is,
and you know,
you had brought this up earlier and I
wanted to point out we had talked about,
uh,
people growing up,
young people today and whether or not
they're going to go back,
in other words say,
oh,
this is all so far beyond where we
should go back.
Or if they're going,
this is the new normal to them.
To them,
they don't even remember when Dan Carlin
talks about the laws of the fourth
amendment,
they're going,
what?
You know,
I don't even remember what you were
saying.
You know,
God,
that'd be crazy to let people do that or
whatever.
I mean,
you wonder if,
if once you haven't had a freedom for a
while,
does it seem radical to go back to that?
There was a great quote,
I use it all the time by a historian a
longtime ago named Charles Austin beard,
and he said to be considered a dangerous
radical today,
all you have to do is go around spouting
the phrases of the founding fathers
that'll get you on the NSA watchlist
today.
What does it mean?
You know,
if you,
if you take that out,
so smacking the mic.
But if you take that out and you try to
analyze that,
what does that say about how far we've
come,
you know,
revolutionaries create your country and
then we very quickly lose that
revolutionary ardor and we become much
more conservative,
which is natural I think.
But you know,
we'd talked about life cycles of
countries.
Are we over the hill?
I mean,
could you make a case that the United
States concept,
which is really a utopian one,
this,
we can all be free.
We can all run the cut.
Is that something that is past its
prime?
It's sell by date.
Well I think the the corrupt amongst us
have tried to whittle away at it like
you're talking about the fourth
amendment or the second amendment or
even the first amendment.
Any the amendments were you look at the
freedoms that people were really worried
about losing and when something like the
Patriot Act or the Patriot Act gets
passed and you realize that they can
just sorta detain you and they don't
have to charge you with anything and
they can detain you indefinitely if they
just decide.
They don't have to present you with any
evidence.
They don't have to give you a trial.
They don't have to give you a court
date.
Like,
well,
okay,
well what are we operating under?
Then if you have,
if you can make an act like that and
that sort of dissolves the constitution
and the bill of rights for people who
you decide are the bad guys.
If you can just do that,
then we don't really have the protection
of the constitution and the bill
were talking about earlier the
corruption where you'd mentioned the
second amendment.
Why isn't the second amendment is in as
much trouble as the fourth,
for example,
an IRA?
Because there's money,
right?
There's some money on one.
There's an industry.
That's right.
And so and listen,
I'm okay with that.
I mean if you're gonna,
if you're going to to to create a group
and get a lot of money to defend an
amendment to the constitution.
Even if Americans argue what the second
amendment means,
but I love the idea of money coming to
legislators because that's what they pay
attention to to protect those rights.
My problem is that the amendments that
are getting shafted are the ones that
don't have a lot of money and often have
a lot of money on the other side.
Yeah.
Well it's just bizarre that you could
get so much done with money and that
this is our system of government and
it's slowly but surely crept its way
into the root system of it and just
entangled it and choked it down and
natural though.
I mean,
I think.
I think that that basically this is the
way it always is and we would have had
to have held it back with all of our
force to keep it from doing it because
money has a way,
doesn't it?
I mean we all,
we all are vulnerable.
Once you have enough money so that you
don't have to be vulnerable.
It's different,
but I mean if you are just a person
struggling to get by and somebody who
offer somebody offers you a lot of money
to do something,
it is a heck of a challenge to have,
okay,
here are my philosophical beliefs.
Here's food for my children or whatever.
That becomes very difficult and with
these legislators,
the PD is that they all want to be
reelected so much that they can let the
money sway them.
Though if they didn't care that much
about the jobs,
the money might not mean that much.
That once you get elected,
if you said this is all I want,
then you don't care what the money says.
You only care what the money.
He says if you want to get reelected,
which argues for term limits and all
that stuff maybe.
Yeah,
no,
you're right.
You're right.
It's just,
boy,
it is daunting when you sit down and
talk about it like this.
I know I always come in here and bring
you down.
I'm sorry.
I do whatever you want to have a guest
after me to cleanse your palate is what
he said about David Duke.
David Duke is a bad person who had
disavowed numerous occasions over the
years.
Trumps had an MSL.
This is not the first time though.
This is after he got slammed for not
doing enough to disavow.
So in other words,
this is like the,
the follow up question in the fall.
So the first time he said something
like,
I don't want to miss quarter,
but I recall him saying something like,
I don't know anything about the KKK or
something like that.
And everybody lost their minds.
But if you,
if you said to yourself,
okay,
five percent of my support is from
people who would like a guy like David
Duke.
I'm not going to cut out five percent of
my support.
I don't know.
The whole thing is surreal to me a
little bit.
Once again,
you know,
if I've been caught off guard by
anything,
I've been caught off guard by this and I
can't process it yet.
I don't know how to.
I don't know how to fit Donald Trump and
that one segment of his supporters into
my worldview because I thought they were
a dying breed.
I didn't think that could be
resurrected.
I talked to a guy when I was a reporter
during the Bosnian war and he was a
Croat and he tried to make the case to
me and he very well might have been
right that a lot of those people in that
area where they have historic problems
with each other and always have.
We're getting along just fine.
While economic things were okay when he
said we were intermarrying,
you know,
serves could fall in love with Croats.
It was,
it was going okay,
but he goes,
once everything hit the fan and times
became tough and the economics came into
play.
All those old feelings came back and I
thought to myself,
is that something that is applicable
on this racism thing?
I don't.
I don't know,
but one could make a case that we
haven't been this unsettled in a very
long time in this country.
Are we seeing A.
I dunno.
It's hard to factor how much that plays
a role versus how much the Internet and
the ability for these people to speak
out when before they would have had to
be xeroxing things and leaving them on
your car.
You know when you come out of the
grocery store,
did you ever get one of those things
come into the grocery store?
He has some racist track on your car
window or something.
You never got to raise this one,
but I've got ones for carwashes.
What about the tony allow you ever get
the one that Tony Alamo ones.
He was famous.
He Tonio Lama.
He ran his own religious thing.
Here is something that you used to have
people twice a week.
I'd have that on my car,
but in the old days that's how somebody
had to do it.
Now they have a broad class platform.
Are we just hearing from these people
more because they can speak to more
people while they also can find
likeminded group.
That's true.
I mean you couldn't find that many
likeminded groups.
If you lived in a neighborhood full of
progressive people and you were like a
really conservative person,
it'd be really kind of difficult for you
to.
True.
You'd have to seek these people out and
now it's with a couple clicks of the
mouse and all of a sudden,
boom,
you're on some website or a bunch of
people who agree with you and wind each
other up.
Everybody winds up,
by the way,
let's not pick sides.
That happens on all sides.
Get to go to the daily coast and places
like this.
Hey,
wind people up and they also.
They're apologists and they're not
honest about the faults of their.
Like there was this thing about Hillary,
about,
like I said,
it was people were talking about how
it's sexist that people are commenting
on her health and that if it was a,
a man that was running for president who
got week during nine slash 11 during,
you know,
after some sort of a service for the
fallen troops that that would be totally
acceptable.
Like that's not true.
No history shows it because people
forget that they,
uh,
George mcgovern had to drop his vice
presidential candidate because the guy
who had been released that he had
visited a psychiatrist for some shock
shock therapy.
That's right.
Yeah.
He had on more than one occasion had
electroshock therapy,
right?
Because he was a fucking loon and he's
not.
Well,
maybe he wasn't Joe Rogan.
Maybe you're just playing into the
propaganda,
get shocked to fix your brain.
And then a couple of years later
running,
there's only one way to find out that's
true.
I mean,
maybe getting shocked is awesome.
You know what?
Maybe the shark color was in the,
in the hands of voters,
we can get something done in this
country.
One more time.
The president makes a wrong move.
Dick Cheney,
I'd love to have a shock button.
There's a couple of people.
John Bolton,
I'd love a shock,
but I think a lot of the people that are
really excited about hillary becoming
president are excited because it would
be a first,
first time a woman.
I would like that aspect of it myself.
Yeah,
and it would make a.
is make us feel like we're progressing,
that we can find the best candidate in
that regardless of sex.
The real question isn't that the real
question is,
is that the best we can do?
Because if that's the best woman we've
got,
that's crazy.
That doesn't make any sense.
She's the most qualified.
She's also under to criminal
investigation simultaneously.
She's also like,
I'm not a conspiracy theorist for the
most part,
but how many people have died that have
crossed them?
I don't go there.
Have you ever seen it?
Yeah.
What's the number?
I don't know,
but I'll tell you.
I'll tell you this.
Here's where I go.
I go to a much more concrete place,
which is look at who she's speaking to
and look at who she's raising money from
and look at what they released,
the transcripts and those banks.
Oh,
see.
And to me that she shouldn't have,
she shouldn't have a choice in that.
Right?
How is it possible?
She does,
but because she keeps it a secret,
what does that encourage?
Joe Rogan leaks,
right hand hackings.
And so if you didn't keep that a secret,
you could legitimately say,
listen,
there are certain things that the public
should know when you keep things from
the public that they should know.
A lot of the public goes,
well,
the heck with that.
That ought to be elite.
You know,
it's almost like the trying to hold back
as many leaks as possible before
November just until it's too late.
Exactly.
We've got to hold it back once she's in.
She's in.
But there's so many leaks now.
It's just,
it's getting so strange.
When I quoted in the last program I did,
I think it was a Dana milbank column.
Um,
he had talked about one of the recent
links that say,
okay,
don't get hassled by Russian hackers all
the time,
or people that are mad that I could talk
about Russian hackers or what,
sorry dudes,
I know so,
so,
but,
but milbank had said that these people
had had hacked the records and then
release them,
but they also had altered something and
then released that version two and so
they trip themselves up so that you
could compare these are the documents
they hacked.
Then these are the ones that they
released to the public and they had
altered something.
And I said,
everyone,
when they found that story out,
breathe a sigh of relief because now you
have an out and you see it already.
The DNC is going well,
listen,
Russian hackers are known to alter this
stuff.
So the minute that came out,
it was the greatest boon to all the
politicians in the world because they
can say whatever that says is probably
altered.
You know,
so it,
it's,
it's the wonderful get out of jail free
card on the.
Well that is true,
but it's legitimate to.
Because if they really did that well,
that is a get out of jail free card.
So now the hacking is just muddied the
waters even more.
It certainly has.
I mean I would actually probably support
a hack if I was running for president in
that in that sense,
because you could say,
look,
you're not going to trust evidence that
came from someone who got it through
illegal means and they are doing it.
Why would we trust that the hackers
would be the only ones who wouldn't
distort the emails?
What do you got here?
Column.
Did you confirms leaked emails?
Are you see what he said in his emails?
Oh my Quinton's out Dick and girls.
He also talked about Hillary Clinton and
Hubris and all those kinds of things,
which,
you know,
I mean I think.
I think that's the impression she gives.
So it's interesting to hear that people
who know and liker feel a little of that
too is also very suspicious.
But she has already said,
we have this phrase,
I would rather not have to vote for her.
Although she is a friend.
I respect a seven year old person with a
long track record,
unbridled ambition,
greedy,
non,
not transformational with a husband
still dicking Bimbos at home.
Holy Shit.
First of all,
how dare he use the term Bimbos?
I am triggered.
You're not supposed to use that term.
That's a derogatory term towards.
Never come out though.
So he's coming for a guys had retard 40
minutes ago.
Oh boy.
But that's what I'm saying.
I'm going to get some blowback from this
Joe Rogan.
You know that for real?
Yeah.
Stop hanging out with.
I know it's probably bad for you.
I know it is bad for me.
Nah.
How can a guy like Colin Powell or even
Hillary Clinton have all of this stuff
written in emails?
Like are they that out of touch that
this stuff is being tracked or like they
should know that it's being tracked.
I think they felt like they could get
away with a lot more than they can get
away with and I think again,
we're talking about people who grew up
and started behaving a certain way way
before there was this level of
transparency.
You're thinking they should behave
differently.
That's not how these people are.
They're thinking now how can I not use
that email problem again?
They change you behavior change the
behavior they want to change is using
email.
That's the behavior.
They're just thinking that they sort of
adapted to the times.
That was the political landscape back
then.
I think the political landscape today is
just way different.
You have to literally literally thank
everybody is watching everything you
say.
We talked about Clinton and and and,
and women Kennedy.
The press knew that Kennedy was doing
all that stuff,
but there was an unwritten gentleman's
agreement that you didn't talk about
that kind of stuff.
Nevermind.
That he might've been having sex with,
with Sam Giancana,
his girlfriend,
judith exner at the same time,
and that there might be some problems
with that nowadays.
I mean,
that's why to me,
you know,
people say Bill Clinton was just
impeached over sex in my mind,
anybody who's either dumb enough or
whatever name you want to put in there
that he thinks he can get away with,
that is somebody I don't want with the
hand on the nuclear button.
I mean,
come on.
Anybody with half a brain knows.
I mean,
Joe,
if you wanted to get away with
something,
which you pull that one,
I mean,
come on.
There's no way he was 100 percent going
to get caught and did it anyway.
That's not good judgment.
Well,
that kind of guy who becomes president
is usually a deck.
Sullinger no domestic George.
I don't think the elder George Bush
falls into that category and maybe he
not prudent.
Maybe.
Maybe he didn't explain,
but maybe he did.
Maybe that explained his wife.
Like she's just hanging out and he was
like,
Hey,
I'm going to go dixon.
He was a fighter pilot.
I never knew a fighter pilot who wasn't
a little bit,
you know,
get around.
Yeah,
they're savages.
Savage.
You want them that way,
but living on the edge,
but those are going to get all the
fighter pilots right in me.
See,
I mean this is a terrible show for good
men.
Those fighter pilots,
they're great men.
There was a high incidence of swinger
behavior.
Was that,
was that the fifties and sixties or was
that the fighter pilot who was a um,
there was a study done.
No,
it was a conversation between this guy
and a fighter pilots about the high
incidences of swingers and one of the
things that I think they were saying,
I forget where I read this,
but there were saying that what was
going on was that these guys were in
such
an intense job where there's a high
likelihood of them dying and one of the
ways to ensure that their loved one
would be looked after is if someone
loved them as much as they loved them.
So they would literally be in these
fighter runs with these planes flying
into hostile territory.
Getting shot at thinking any day could
be my last day.
So this desperation of like you're
leaving behind a wife and a family.
And they one way they alleviated that
this was the,
the idea was that they would wife swap
and that it happened naturally.
You know who it was.
I think it was Chris Ryan.
I think it was Chris Ryan there was
explaining this light.
Chris Ryan.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure it was him.
I'm now.
I'm like reasonably sure.
But that kind of makes sense because
when you're someone who's every day
world is life and death on a level that
a fighter pilot is.
I mean that is that.
See the risk taker thing where you said
these are people who live on the edge
because that's there when you.
You fly those planes,
you're a risk taker.
If you wanted to say,
okay,
a person who is willing to do risky
behavior here.
I'm not thinking of the wife swapping as
much as,
as having a lot of girlfriends that
aren't even a wife,
but,
but at the same time,
listen,
like you said,
some of those personality traits are
probably what you want in those guys.
Yeah.
Well,
I think with the way Chris was
explaining it to was that their bond and
their comradery between each other was
so powerful that it's sort of a,
it's sort of the clips,
jealousy in a way,
you know,
because they counted on each other so
much and they were brothers in war and
literally life or death struggle.
So there a bond and a comradery that
sort of superseded everything and that
the idea of like they could swap wives
and they just love each other more.
It's kind of crazy.
So I go with the outcomes rather that
they're more like pro athletes and
they're just,
they're just wall or,
or just there.
There's this swagger you'd mentioned.
The swagger,
right?
It's all part of the,
of what kind of keeps them.
The kind of guys that can be fighter
pilots,
you know,
maybe it'll come with the territory.
Maybe it's a bunch of those things too,
you know,
let's be honest,
there were fighter pilots who never did
anything like that.
Absolutely.
Given the get out of jail free pass,
that's my Dan Carlin get in the car
listening to his podcast.
He's guys are assholes,
assholes.
Why do you listen?
Fighter pilots are swingers youth pizza.
You know,
what just happened?
A bunch of wives turned to their x
fighter pilot husbands and says,
honey,
that didn't involve you.
Did it wife swap in a new reality show,
wife swap and fighter wife swap and
fighter pilots,
you know,
for those who have not seen all of the
appearances I've had on this.
Joe started off,
you know,
breaking me into being on the Joe Rogan
podcast with some,
some,
uh,
some comments initially.
So now I just flow with it and it's
gonna get me killed eventually,
but it's not gonna do anything mad.
It's a conversation with this.
This is just like,
if you and I went out to dinner in
between bites of food,
we would have probably the same
conversations about stuff.
Funny.
What,
what do you like when you see what the
reports are about the Clinton
Foundation?
I don't totally understand what's legal
and what's not legal,
but I don't think I've seen anyone said
that anything they've done is illegal.
Right?
It skirts.
Yeah.
It falls into that category.
The same category that,
um,
maybe the giving of ambassadorships to
people who give money fall into the,
for example,
the clinic.
There's no question that the Clinton
Foundation goes and does good work.
There's no question,
but how much does the fact that they do
good work and that your name is attached
to it ended up being something that
helps you for less charitable reasons,
right?
In other words,
it makes you look good as a candidate to
be somebody that you know,
helps vaccine people against polio.
Right?
So all of that right there has a
subsidiary effect that you could,
if you wanted to say,
oh,
you're,
you're benefiting from this will now add
the fact that you know,
people can give money to the foundation.
Then the foundation can pay Bill Clinton
to run the mean.
It becomes.
And then if you gave money to the
foundation,
does that mean you get special
treatment?
I can hear the Hillary Clinton
supporters saying,
well,
that didn't happen,
but it's the reason that people put
stuff in a blind trust when they become
president so that you don't even know
what your money's doing.
So that you can't possibly be favoritism
toward one and,
and the Clintons have basically made it
sound like they're not going to do that.
And once again,
as I said to you earlier,
if you know they're after you,
like thereafter the Clintons,
wouldn't,
you just get leave as much room between
you and any potential width of scandal
as you could,
but they don't.
I don't know why they don't,
but they don't Ken,
that maybe they can't
at this point,
you know,
how could they,
they probably are so and all those other
people that have been a part of all that
stuff for so long.
Well,
and you know,
you've done this and I've done this,
we both been around some of these high
rollers before where you realize how
much they pick up the phone and talk to
other high rollers and how
interconnected network is.
And there's nothing wrong with that
intrinsically,
but you could easily see that that
networking can be used for nefarious
purposes,
good purposes or no purposes,
but they all have each other on speed
dial.
Right?
That's natural.
Yeah.
It does seem natural.
I mean,
podcasts of have,
we do have that is a little known fact
is you and I to podcasters who learned
about each other,
the moonlight on you sometimes just
moonlight on you as well,
sir.
Yeah,
I mean people in the same business talk
to each other and become tight and it
affect like,
you know,
it affects,
it affects the way they do business for
sure.
And it doesn't even necessarily have to
be like some that really carefully
scripted agreement is almost like a
known thing.
Exactly right.
I think and you know what and and in
the,
in the era of hacks and all that,
isn't that the
smarter way to comport yourself,
right.
Nixon,
because he was a taper,
knew when he had to have an important
discussion with somebody.
He wanted to make sure it was safe.
They went for a walk,
right?
And they went for a walk past the White
House.
They got in the weeds out there and then
they had the discussion and then they
use the n word or whatever,
whatever it might be,
but the point clear.
That's right,
but think about this in 10 years,
in 10 years,
how is this email hack scandal have
going to change a protocol on how all
these people do things?
Because it is,
you watch Colin Powell and everybody
watching what's unfolding right now are
determining that there are going to be
new ways we communicate and it's not
going to be like that.
Well,
there's two different hacks,
right?
There's the DNC hack and then there's a
hillary server hack,
right?
Aren't they different hacks?
Because the DNC,
ar,
and then there'll be.
And from what I heard,
I told you,
I heard there was a republican national
committee hack too.
I love the fact that they fired that
woman.
Oh,
did you found something?
It's not sure.
I'm the guy that said it,
said he misspoke.
Oh,
that came out later.
Mr Scott makes me more suspicious than
anything.
God Damn.
Ms Dot Booker's.
I just think it's hilarious that,
uh,
the woman who got outed in the DNC hacks
as being this woman who is conspiring to
like put down Bernie and help Hillary,
like that woman,
she had a step down.
It was immediately hired by the Clinton
campaign.
I mean,
there's zero transparency.
it's so obvious.
Corruption,
let's call it what it.
And the corruption is both parties and
we have no options besides the bulk
part.
So this is where,
you know,
like we said on the common sense tool
for 11 years now,
this is your focal point of the problem.
We have a corruption problem.
Both parties benefit from it.
They have no real interest in addressing
it.
The only time they're interested in
fighting corruption is that they can
manage to fight the kind of corruption
that helps the other side without
impacting the ones that help them.
So the Republicans always say that about
democratic campaign finance reform,
that it goes after Republican funders
but not democratic ones.
In other words,
they're not,
they're not holier than thou,
they're just trying to figure out
another way to game the system,
utilizing reform as the tool.
I mean,
they have to do in some way.
They're all complicit in similar sorts
of situations,
but the,
the thing that was so weird,
I think I said not transparent,
all I met completely transparent.
The thing that was weird about how
transparent it was is that there wasn't
even a gap in time of this woman getting
fired and then getting an appearance
purposes.
Right.
It was like instantaneous.
It's like we don't care.
We're just going to do it.
I,
yeah,
she helped me out.
She hooked me up.
She's my girl that,
that's just like what you said about
Hillary Clinton.
Uh,
um,
and the fact that she had said that the
FBI director said this about her when he
had just said something kind of
complete,
but she knew that the five percent of
people that would realize that didn't
count.
Same thing.
The five percent of people who realize,
wait a minute,
you just hired that cast.
She's not after those pieces.
There's another day and more news
stories and a plane goes down in
Singapore or something,
and then there's another news story and
some fucking nuclear tests in North
Korea and everybody's gone.
It's gone.
Three weeks later it's gone.
There's just so much going on that you
can't really maintain any story like
that in the news.
That's why the Glenn Greenwald,
Edward Snowden,
the way that they approach that was
structured the way it was to come out in
chunks because they had said if you
release it all at once,
it'd be this huge story,
but then it's done.
If you.
If you understand how the news cycle
works the way you just mentioned,
you want to release a nice chunk and
then wait until the headlines die down
again and we start moving and then
release another chunk and that's the way
these wiki leaks is doing that right now
with these hacks they have.
They're releasing it in chunks because
as soon as the news cycle dies down,
they want to take advantage of the next
one.
The wiki leaks thing is one of the most
bizarre scenarios where you have this
guy that if you asked the United States
or just the United States,
like what percentage of people support
with Julian assange dead?
What surprised what percentage of the
people support letting people understand
what is really going on behind the
scenes be pretty overwhelming.
I would guarantee you be in the high
seventies.
Some people are blindly patriotic and
they would just want their government to
just have carte blanche.
There's a few of those,
but I think most people would support
the.
Yeah,
I want to know what the fuck's going on
now.
This guy is trapped in an embassy in
London.
You can't go anywhere.
Ecuadorian embassy or something like
that.
Right?
Is it Ecuador?
But he's trapped in this embassy can't
leave and been in this house for your
potential rape charge.
Right?
It's not even a rape charge.
Supplies,
sex.
It's hanging over your head.
I know.
And and,
and he can't leave to go answer the
charges because they'll grab them.
Will,
they'll,
they'll grab him on completely unrelated
purposes or unrelated charges.
It has nothing to do with that.
They just want to hold him there.
I mean,
you really think that they'd be chasing
him for this long because he had sex
without a condom.
All spooning.
No,
we all know that.
What is it?
Swedish court to rule on?
Julian assan facing extradition of
Sweden over sexual assault charges.
The wiki leaks foundation has been
confirmed to a confined to the
Ecuadorian embassy in London for more
than four years.
Huh?
The Ecuadorians to to hold onto it.
That so crazy.
He's been in this house for four years,
but here's what they have to do.
If they want to keep playing the
straight and narrow,
they have to get ahold of some some leak
documents from the other side because
otherwise it's like.
It's like if you only get the leaked
documents from one side,
that does impact the election and that
calls into question the motives of the
leaker.
Right?
If you're saying I release information
right then,
then you can be above the fray.
If you say like a lot of journalists
understand how to do what you omit and
don't release has as much value as what
you do.
Right?
So if the only leaks you're getting are
from the Democrats and the Republicans
aren't being leaked,
then that's influencing the election
because you know as well as I do,
the other side has crap that that is
just as shocking and upsetting and
corrupt as the Democrats.
So let's see that too.
Yeah,
let,
let's see the two and let's see what
trump does when he finds out that,
but all talking shit about him.
You know,
I am ashamed to say that there's a part
of me that says,
yeah,
let's see that I don't want to be that
way,
but I read somebody online said the
other day that there's people who are
going to vote for him just for the
entertainment value because they don't
want to be bored for the next four
years.
And I thought to myself,
that's when the country's really jumped
the shark when we're voting for
candidates,
but I don't care what they'll do.
They're both bad.
I just want the most entertaining.
A lot of people feel that it doesn't
matter.
They're also thinking that what you look
at as a president is really just a
figurehead and the military industrial
job reading that book right now,
American coup.
So mate,
look,
if you look at what Obama promised and
you look at what he actually did,
very different things.
Why people forget the George W dot Bush
actually ran on a more humble foreign
policy.
Do you remember that?
He was going to have people.
He said,
people Americans want a more humble
foreign policy.
Could there be any,
any dichotomy?
Worse than a more humble for polly and
people will say,
well,
nine slash 11 happened.
Yes,
so we attacked Iraq,
didn't make any sense,
and everybody was like,
look,
we're fucking kicking someone's ass all
right enough to shut up and wave that
flag.
I will tell you this.
Anybody who tells me that they support
the troops again but are willing to send
them willy nilly anywhere at anytime.
To me,
supporting the troops means you value
their lives and their families and the
fact that many of these guys and women
who have had to go back and back and
back and their lives have been on hold
and all and they suffer.
I mean,
how many stories have we read about what
these people deal with everyday?
Go to the va and so let's say you want
to support the troops,
fixed the VA,
right?
Do the things that matter to the troops
and then don't send them into harm's way
unless it really,
really matters.
That's supporting the troops.
To me,
you have the problem is we don't know
what is going on when we hear that the
troops need to invade some certain area.
We don't know if it's legit or not.
Legit.
We don't know who the people are that
are making the decisions.
Ultimately classify it and the
classified.
And we also don't think there's,
there's,
there's gotta be some Intel that they're
not sharing that might sway our opinion
one way or the other.
They think that seemed like we were
talking about the,
um,
the Gulf of Tonkin resolution,
the last commonsense show with the Gulf
of Tonkin resolution.
There were parts of it very important
parts of it that were not released until
2005,
2005 if it,
if you found out within a month that the
Gulf of Tonkin,
which for those who don't know,
this is sort of the,
the excuse for why we were able to ramp
up the Vietnam war,
which killed a ton of people.
Right.
If you had known within a month in real
time,
basically that didn't happen the way
that they said it happened.
That's time enough to impact the
decision making.
They classified it so that by the time
it comes out,
everyone's dead and it's in a history
book,
you have no ability to impact the
decision making.
That's where classification kills us
because if you,
the electrode say to heck with this,
we've got to go out in the streets or we
have to have a protest online.
You can't do that if you don't know
what's going on.
And that was one of the more ironic
things about Kennedy's assassination was
that they lock the files up for what?
When,
when did the full files on the Kennedy
assassination or allowed to be released,
but they essentially made it so that no
one could investigate it for far longer
than anyone's going to be alive.
Like I think it was like 2010.
Then it prompts suspicion right there
whether or not it's desert.
Why would they do that?
I did.
Well,
I did come up with reasons because I
felt the same way and I had to figure
out a cause.
Right?
What would explain it?
That was rational.
And here's what I came up with and I'm
hardly the only person who realized
this.
You remember Oswald had ties to Cuba and
he defected to the Soviet Union and then
come home.
Okay.
So if your average joe or Jane and you
don't know much about what's going on,
but you find out a Cuban defector,
Cuban supporting Soviet Union defect,
you're killed the president.
And that maybe that might.
I mean,
do you see how that,
you know,
if you were reading the guns of August
on how World War One started and you
thought it wouldn't have taken,
you know,
that that was an assassination to write
in an open top vehicle by somebody and
Serbians were behind that in the way
that the people whose archduke was
killed.
So,
so I mean,
if Americans thought that the Soviet
Union killed their young president,
that they all loved with his wife right
there and the two little children,
what would the,
and you know,
this is not even a year after the Cuban
missile crisis,
how much might that have impacted the
president's ability to keep us out of a
war or not?
I mean,
I can see if somebody said that you
might have a very good reason for hiding
the fact that Oswald had really close
ties.
I don't know.
I was trying to find out a rationale
that made sense to me and that would be
a rationale that made sense to me.
I don't think you have to classify it
for a lifetime,
which they basically did.
What does the year next year,
October 26th,
2017 shit when it comes out.
Redactions will be all over the place.
Oh yeah.
I'm sure you'll have if and,
but or yeah,
I'm sure.
But uh,
I mean they have leaked some stuff or
release some stuff through the Freedom
Information Act that people would
consider incredibly offensive and they
found out about it like 1962 northwoods
operation northwoods where they designed
a tax on Guantanamo Bay.
They were going to arm Cuban friendlies
and attack one tottenham obey,
potentially killing.
Who knows how many soldiers they're
going to blow up a drone jetliner and
blame it on the Cubans all if you look
at the stuff that the CIA was doing.
And I think it's stupid to think that
they don't do the similar things now.
It's,
it's crazy stuff.
Kills a stuff that is so.
And here's the thing,
stuff that is so opposed to the 19
fifties highschool mythology of America
that it's hard to reconcile the two.
And those people will say,
listen,
it's the real world.
Welcome to,
you know,
we were trying to survive.
We had hydrogen
bombs aimed at us.
I mean all that stuff is true,
but how do you reconcile it?
I mean,
yeah,
that was,
that was a giant issue with Kennedy,
you know,
and,
and secrecy itself was a giant issue
with Kennedy,
which is so ironic that they sealed his
death up for 25 years.
You remember that very famous speech
that he had were about secrecy and
government.
Oh yeah.
About transparency being important.
Or my favorite line from Kennedy was
always the one where he says,
those who make peaceful change,
uh,
impossible.
Make violent change.
Inevitable.
I mean,
those are the kinds of things where you
wonder about us now will you say,
listen,
the ability to have our system evolve in
ways that make it better are going to
prevent really bad things from happening
in the future.
If you can't,
if we can't get it together now,
just follow the current trends outward.
If nothing changes,
what is the 20,
20 election gonna look like?
Are you a Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone
type of guy?
I am now.
I changed my mind on that.
I used to.
Got You.
Huh?
Who got,
you know,
here's the thing,
and this is what always upsets me about
the conspiracy theorists.
I love them,
but I wish they wouldn't leave stuff out
of there,
out of their stories that disprove,
that looked bad.
In other words,
not everybody does that.
I don't blame them.
Everybody likes to say,
okay,
I'll show you the things that,
that backup my theory.
But with Oswald,
there were a couple of books that came
out.
Uh,
my friend Vince Bull Yossi had one.
Gerald Posner had another where they
included stuff that was not in all the
conspiracy books that I read and I've
read a lot.
And you say,
okay,
one,
why the hell didn't you put that in
there?
Now I'm mad at you and I don't trust you
as much stuff can be the fact that
Oswald took a shot at a US general
before he took a shot at Kennedy.
Right?
If you figured out that he needed to do
that,
oh God,
I want to say who was the general two to
10 years ago,
I would have remembered his name go.
We have to look up Lee Harvey Oswald.
He took a shot at the general and missed
and with the same rifle I believe,
and it was posner and bull Yossi that
both pointed that out and when you turn
around and go,
okay,
if the guy was really taking a shot at
the US general,
now that changes my overall view of the
Guy Oswald's
earlier attempt to assassinate General
Walker
interest.
And so when you hear that again,
now that might not be anything,
but why'd you leave some of that out of
my conspiracy book?
That's important,
you know,
as an another thing about the Oswald
thing that always bugged me was that
they said that the scope wasn't cited in
properly.
The man lake,
no rifle.
How could he,
how could he get off that shot when the
scope wasn't even cited improperly?
Mike,
how do you know it's not cited
improperly?
You know,
it's not cited improperly because right
after they found it,
they shot with it.
How long did it take for they shot with
it.
Do you know anything about scopes?
Let me tell you something about scopes.
You fucking drop your rifle in the
ground and that thing gets off the
caliber.
It's uncalibrated.
It happens easy.
You could bang your rifle against a log
or a rock or something like that.
I doubt he was putting it down and
carefully after shooting the president.
Not only that,
who the fuck was handling it.
There was so much
shenanigans involved in handling the
right way,
so that argument I reject because when
they said that the gun wasn't cited in
properly,
I'm like,
that does.
That doesn't make any sense.
You have no idea what,
how it was cited in when he pulled the
trigger.
You don't know.
It's so easy to throw off.
Kennedy had pissed off a lot of a lot of
people and so when you talk about a
conspiracy and having motive,
there were a lot of people that had
motive.
I always hate it when they know the
Oliver Stone movie drove me crazy
because in my opinion,
the movie he did on JFK,
he took every conspiracy theory out
there and throw them all in which
discredited all of them to me want to go
with fake general who didn't really
exist.
I them all the information.
I can't do that.
Get me started on him.
No good.
True.
Star John F Kennedy it.
Yeah.
They do that in these movies that are
supposed to be about real history.
Oh,
he did it with the doors and then when
he was,
he was called.
He was called on it.
His answer was this wasn't a movie about
the doors.
In reality was a movie about what I
thought about the doors when I was
fighting in Vietnam,
listening to their music.
Got The dude say that at the beginning
of the film,
put up this.
This is a fictionalized version of what
I thought when I was in such a the great
to.
Yeah,
they alexander the great film to.
You're just going to add this movie.
The snowden movie.
He's got coming out this week.
Oliver Stone didn't get funding for
Stoughton in the US in Germany.
He found both financial support and
filming locations.
First political thriller,
but it's released as low key as a US
trying to keep it under wraps is the US
like visit the US operates as one giant.
That's exactly right.
Yeah.
The press is keeping it down because
they don't want everybody to talk about
the snowden.
If,
if they thought it would make $150,
million dollars,
the studios,
we'd be pushing it left right and center
right now.
They'd love a hit of any kind regardless
of what it said.
What were we just talking about before
you brought that up?
A JFK.
I'm oliver stone stuff into those
movies.
Okay.
So No,
the,
those uh,
I wanted to know what other things led
you to believe that a Lee Harvey Oswald
acted alone?
Well,
I mean originally,
you know,
when you follow the story,
so you see it's not just the fact that,
that it probably happened a certain way.
It's when you follow the conspiracy
talking,
you realize,
you know what they're bringing to the
equation.
How much do I believe the David for the
Cuban idea?
How much do I believe?
And after going through it,
you know,
if you go read like book Yossi his book,
he was the guy who wrote helter skelter.
He prosecuted Manson,
he was a guy I liked a lot and,
and he,
he wrote a book where he did it like a
prosecutor.
So here's how I would have prosecuted
Oswald.
And when he lines it up the way he does,
you sit there and go,
okay,
this is not an I know bull.
You'll see he was a,
he was a guy that would have loved to
have written that it wasn't.
He would have loved to have said Kennedy
was assassinated by a conspiracy,
but he did.
Then he ran down the list and you sit
there and go,
okay,
if I was at the trial and I was on the
jury and they said,
what was the preponderance of evidence?
And did the prosecutor,
you know,
prove his case.
I would have had to have set after
reading [inaudible] book that had less.
I really had a vested
interest in believing the conspiracy
theory that he had done a damn good job
of making his case.
Here's my problem with it and this is
one that for whatever reason I don't see
brought up very often.
I don't think they have to be mutually
exclusive.
I don't think Oswald was innocent.
I think Oswald very well as the might
have shot at the at the present,
but I think it's highly likely they set
up more than one shooter.
I think there's a possibility that
gunfire echoing from that building could
make people think that it was coming
from the grassy knoll,
but there's so many people that said
that gunfire was coming from the grassy
knoll that you have to wonder and you
look at the shots that hit Kennedy,
like the one in his neck.
That's one of the.
One of the more interesting books that I
read about it was a case case closed.
I'm best evidence by David.
Lifted.
Lifted was the one that.
Didn't he say that they put something in
the autopsy and Kennedy's head like
that.
That to me,
by the way,
was it or something,
and that was the part that blew me away
because when we were kids,
uh,
they didn't have the Kennedy autopsy,
you.
And then to eventually release those.
That was shocking and put it in the
book.
Yeah.
Well,
they also changed between Bethesda,
Maryland,
and Dallas in that flight from Dallas to
Bethesda,
they changed the risk,
like what the impact was.
They were calling it a bullet hole in
his neck in Dallas.
And then when it got to Bethesda,
they refer to it as a tracheotomy whole.
Here's my problem.
He was hit from the front end,
from the back,
like it's entirely possible that Oswald
also was involved and that there was a
bunch of people involved.
It's entirely possible that if you're
going to assassinate the president,
if you're going to have a conspiracy to
assassinate the president,
you're gonna use a bunch of people.
Why wouldn't they use someone like
Oswald?
Why wouldn't they use some crazy fuck
who emigrates to Russia and comes back
with a Russian wife and he's involved in
communist propaganda and all sorts of
other crazy,
unsavory,
shitty shoots.
It generals.
Yeah,
that's it.
Exactly.
A guy you would use and he might've been
involved to.
It might have been,
and I don't know,
somehow or another it always the.
The debate is always a mutually
exclusive thing.
Either Oswald acted alone or the CIA
killed Kennedy or the NSA.
Who the fuck with the Cubans,
the mob and they blamed it on Oswald.
Well,
it's.
It could totally be.
He was a part of it all and that there
was more than one shooter.
That seems to me to be the most likely
thing.
It's certainly possible when Jack Ruby
runs up to him and shoots him in front
of all those cops,
those cops were walking them out there
and there was assassination.
They're holding onto his arm.
We've got them.
We've got the guy who shot the president
out in the open,
in front of everybody.
Who was that?
A guy with a gun.
Oh No,
mine.
The guy who.
Who was my mentor when I first started
in news was a local guy here that
everybody knows new guide him,
John Babcock and babcock was a Texas guy
originally and he was in the motorcade
in the very last car because they had
press writing and the so far,
but
he was in the motorcade,
so they went.
He was at Parkland when,
when it was announced at Kennedy was
dead and then he was.
He told me the story.
He had good stories.
He had good Manson stories too.
He was in the room with ruby before they
brought Oswald out before ruby killed
him and he said,
what are you doing here today?
Jack and Jack,
and he had a conversation beforehand.
I don't recall what John Thought in
terms of conspiracy or not conspiracy,
but I remember that that was like a
seminal moment in his career because he
was broadcasting live.
He was on the radio while it was all
going on and he was there at the scene.
He also had the most awesome Manson
stuff because I'm.
The station I worked at KBC was big in
the Manson investigation.
They're the ones that actually found the
bloody clothes a year later on the
hillside while they were filming a
recreation and that's how the bloody
clothes got found and he would go and
speak to Manson all the time through the
Manson was not convicted yet,
so he's on trial and awaiting trial and
he had Manson became friends and up on
his wall he had a photo of Charles
Manson within Pencil,
a note and I still remember what it
said.
It said to the trial,
come early,
stay late.
It will be quite a show.
And he said,
look at that,
writing that Manson data.
And I looked at it and it was weird.
You could see that the pencil was
broken,
like he would snap the point off the
pencil,
every couple of words.
He said,
do you know why the point of the pencil
snapped?
I go,
no.
He goes,
[inaudible].
The guy had no education,
but he was pretty smart and he used to
get so frustrated at his inability to
express himself that break the pencil.
So then once he was convicted and
remember he was sent to death row.
John said,
I stopped paying attention to him
because you know,
he's on death row.
I'm moving on.
So manson started sending him messages
saying,
why don't you come and visit me anymore?
And so finally John went and he said,
Manson said,
so why don't you come and visit me
anymore?
And John said,
well,
you know,
Charlie,
you're going to the.
And Manson says,
so you don't think I can,
you know,
you don't think I'm.
And he goes,
no.
So he said,
come back in a week.
And so John says,
so I come back in a week and all Manson
did was slide under the table,
like a cocktail Napkin type thing and on
it was drawn the layout of John's house.
And he said,
I went home and I bought three shotguns
and I put them in loaded in various
parts of my house.
He says,
they're still there to this day,
but basically wouldn't that scare the
hell out of you that have somebody draw?
In other words,
he'd sent somebody to John's house to go
look around and then tell them what it
looked like and then sending the
cocktail that African.
He had so many good stories that old.
He was old fashioned news guy,
but he was in the Kennedy thing and we
used to talk about that all the time and
now I wish I could remember 50 year old
brain bus speed.
What John had told me about his thinking
on it.
I guess.
I guess my attitude is I'm always
disinclined to believe conspiracy
theories and less.
The preponderance of evidence convinces
me otherwise.
What we talked about when I read it,
we talked about the Gulf of Tonkin.
That's an absolute false flag that was
perpetrated on the American public
resulting in us going to war,
ramping up the war,
killing.
Who knows how many people,
but everybody that the people in
government don't have to sweat the Kent.
Okay.
All the people around Kennedy were
Kennedy's people,
and so whether you're talking about the
defense secretary or a lot of the whiz
kids,
they were called when Kennedy brought in
these new people from private industry.
They were his people and they stayed in
the Johnson administration.
Those people would have had to.
I mean,
if they had thought that their boss who
brought them into government had been
killed by Johnson or by the government.
I mean,
it just,
it's,
it's hard to believe what.
How do they know?
How would you know?
Okay.
If you're all in an office and you're
working with president gets shot,
you think you're going to get more
information than the average person on
the street.
You're probably not.
You're probably going to have to read
the news reports just like everybody
else.
You're going to see Oswald paraded out
there.
You're gonna.
See Jack Ruby,
shoot them.
You're going to have people in your
organization tell you that they shot the
guy who shot the president and you're
going to believe it until you see this
approved or film until you watching the
Geraldo Rivera show.
And Dick Gregory brings on the Zapruder
film.
What was it like 10 years later?
And I remember this wasn't like 10 years
later.
Well,
what year did it wasn't like they
assassinated him in 63 and I don't think
he made it on the Dick Gregory show
until the 19 seventies.
No,
it was late seventies to I think,
or the Geraldo Rivera show.
Was it then?
Here's the question either if it wasn't
the government.
So look at all the different people that
Oliver Stone could throw into a film,
right?
Which the Mafia or whatever.
If it's not the government,
then the government has no reason at all
to cover it up.
Right,
okay.
If the mafia does it,
Robert F Kennedy is going after the
mafia all the time anyway.
It just gives him one more reason to go.
So the only way this becomes a
conspiracy that stays secret and,
and involves the government not
investigating it,
is if the government is in on it.
So that's the only conspiracy theory
that makes sense on why the government
didn't pursue the conspiracy theory.
Okay.
So if the government is in on it,
well,
how many people have to be in on it?
See,
here's the thing.
If,
if the narrative that they can find,
they didn't compartmentalize,
that was standard.
I do everything,
everything is compartmentalized and
there's a need to know basis and you
know,
unless you're some dude in a movie who
wants to get to the bottom of it and he
was sneaking into the building in the
middle of the Warren Commission report
and the magic bullet,
all that stuff is,
is part of the cover up if you buy that
theory while the Warren Commission
report in and of itself is what lyft and
uses and a reason to go in and start
investigating the Kennedy assassination.
Well,
as I told it was a good reason to have
covered it up.
If you believe that the American people
would draw a natural conclusion that a
Soviet agent killed our president and
remember,
you know,
Kennedy had been trying to assassinate
Castro to.
So there were reasons for a Cuban group
of people to take.
I mean,
there's a lot of enemies.
There's a lot of enemies also in
government.
He was trying to get rid of the CIA.
He was trying to do a lot of stuff that
people didn't like,
the speech that he gave about
transparency,
about secret secrets and secret
societies being a damaging part of our
culture.
Does that mean that was all.
That's all not good if you want to stay
alive.
Well,
and I want to make it clear when it
comes to these kinds of theories,
I try to have an open mind and,
and,
you know,
try to look at every angle and I'm not
saying that these things are not
possible.
You had asked me if I had a view and I
used to have one view and now I have
another view.
Uh,
if evidence came out tomorrow that said
that made it look like it was a
conspiracy or I would be perfectly happy
to switch again.
I mean,
I try,
I try to,
to be flexible on these things.
I don't have a vested interest.
So when you say those things,
I kind of go,
okay,
yeah,
I can see that.
It's not what I believe lately,
but I can see that.
Yeah.
I don't really believe anything when it
comes to that.
It becomes the Kennedy assassination,
other than some fuckery was a foot well
and the story when the conspiracy
theorists who write these books and it's
an industry as you well know,
I get angry when they don't include
things that might disprove what they
say,
you want me to believe you?
I want.
I want you to lay it all right,
and so I became suspicious.
Once those books started coming forward
saying,
well,
look what they left out here and look
what they left out here.
And you go,
okay,
well now you never told me that.
You know,
there's some tightly grooved paths when
it comes to discussing that scarcity.
That's why I've always found it so weird
that no one mentions or very rarely is
it mentioned that Oswald might've been a
part of it.
The idea that he got off those three
shots because they determined that it
was three shots based on people's
reporting and you know,
if you,
if you believe that he got off those
three shots in a shorter amount of time
and then you see Jesse Ventura trying to
recreate it and say it's impossible.
No one dropped all.
Well,
someone can do that.
That's not true.
Like there,
there's people that are capable of
getting off three shots in six seconds
or whatever it was.
And,
and if I recall Oswald was a marksman.
Look,
it's him.
He probably was okay with a rifle.
But if you're leaning,
here's the reality,
you're leaning on a window sill and
you've got a scope with the bolt action.
Ancient rifleman.
I mean if you really wanted to kill the
president,
a mail order man,
liquor carcanos rifle is not what you
would achieve that shooting that far of
a shot?
No,
I mean,
what,
how many yards was it?
You know,
and plus after the first one you just
spray Kinda,
you just pull the trigger a couple
times.
But if someone else was involved,
that's where it gets even weirder.
Like he shooting down someone shooting
from the front.
That seems like what they would do if
they were trying to kill somebody.
If it's a conspiracy theory
triangulation,
although let's be honest,
that becomes a lot harder to hide later.
Right?
So if you're worried about exposure,
because exposure would would show the
tentacles and well then you want to make
it as cut and dried and simple as you
can.
You start triangulating on a president
that you know you don't know as you well
know what those bullets are going to do,
right?
I think you open yourself up to massive
problems.
If those bullets go.
I mean if in other words,
if something had gone another way and it
would have been impossible to deny that
there was another shooter,
how does that change the whole
investigation but actually did happen.
That was part of the investigation
itself leading to the magic bullet
theory.
The magic bullet theory was was the well
was created because a guy was walking
under the underpass and the Kerbstone
got hit by a bullet.
He was hitting her head with a ricochet.
So because he was hit with a ricochet,
they found the spot with a bullet.
It hit and they had accounted for one
bullet.
So then they had the head shot that
killed Kennedy,
and then they had this neck thing and
then they had this other bullet.
And then they started like trying to
figure out,
well how many bullets are involved here
and how does colony connolly rather have
a bullet lodged in his,
in his leg,
like how does this happen?
Or how did he get shot?
And a bullet that shattered his bone and
went through his leg also went through
Kennedy.
Is that what we're saying?
Like what are we saying?
So they had to come up with that one
bullet,
doing all that damage specifically
because somebody got hit with some
spray.
That's mean that that did happen.
That was okay.
Part of the investigation,
there's a part c and this is the part
where it's kind of hard if,
if,
if you want there to be anything cut and
dried.
If you're the Warren Commission report
and you're doing this not that long
after Kennedy's assassination,
I think you have to allow for the idea
that there are going to be unknowables
right?
And especially ballistics,
ballistics or crazy write bullets,
tumble bullets and you know,
you fire 900 bullets.
It's something,
most of them are going to be deformed,
but some of them might not be,
but they're never going to look like
that.
Pristine bullet is bullshit.
That's the most bullshit aspect of the
entire investigations.
That's silly bullet.
What does that a t shirt,
Kennedy assassination or how it would
have had to travel through
body to surprise me.
Bullets can do that.
Can hit bones and you'd ricochet and you
tumble
and this is not totally accurate to.
This gets exaggerated like the entry
point and the exit point,
but the point is when bullets hit bone,
they bend and they changed shape.
When bullets don't hit bone,
when you shoot bullets into ballistic
gel or when you shoot them into water
especially,
they don't form that bullet.
Looked like a bullet that was shot
through something soft.
Look at it there so it doesn't look like
what a bullet looks like when it hits
bone and that that hit bone.
It shattered connolly's wrist,
that same bullet and they apparently
just found it on his Gurney in the
hospital and we're supposed to think
that that's a bullet that went through
Kennedy and connally and it's.
I've never talked to a single actual
ballistics expert or firearms
enthusiasts that believes that.
No.
See,
this is where she had I known I was
coming here.
I would have brought both those books
will be.
Could've looked up how the POC and
posing or explain the magic bullet
because they the path,
it
can be explained.
I think bullets hit things that people
have had bullets ricochet around inside
someone's skull and come out there.
I,
when you shoot them in the face of weird
things happen with bullets when they hit
bones and they ricochet and they move
around,
so that's the path of the bullet.
Seems crazy but possible.
What's weird is that they think that is
the bullet.
That doesn't make any sense at all.
If they just said,
that's a bullet that we found and maybe
you know,
he had another one.
I mean maybe something hit something
else.
Maybe,
I don't know,
but saying that that went really points
to the conspiracy.
Yes,
it does.
To me,
it points to people being full of Shit.
The fact that they conveniently founded
on the Gurney way.
Okay.
So the government,
you say,
okay,
okay.
I guess what I'm saying is outcomes
razor.
You're not going to have to convince me
of that.
I'm also that the Warren Commission
report might've had all sorts of
domestic and foreign policy reasons for
doing what it did and just imagine if
you're the CIA in 1962 and you,
uh,
you're getting together with all your
cronies and you've been responsible for
Jack and people all over the world and
you got this guy and he's going to
disband your entire organization,
you know,
and then you're talking to some other
people that are upset at them because of
the Bay of pigs and he talking about
some other people that are upset about
them because of this and have that and
all the other things that he's trying to
do that people don't agree with.
And they go,
look,
there's a simple solution to this.
And then you bring in that Lee Harvey
Oswald character and you get that ball
rolling.
You setup a bunch of different people
that are really good at rifles.
It's,
I think it's totally possible.
It's one of the most.
Wait,
wait,
conspiracy.
It's totally possible branch.
You don't bank on it.
I mean it's also possible.
Here's one thing that always bugged me
about the router film.
When you watch his head,
his head does go back into the left.
But the spray from the bullet in my eyes
seems like it's going forward.
Like he was hit from behind an exit
wound.
Yeah.
Well it seems like a little bit of it.
But then sometimes when you hit someone
like you could hit things and just the
impact of the bullet causes a
reverberation.
And also if you watch,
there's a lot of executions online.
And I'm ashamed to say I've seen some,
all of them all.
If there's a new one tomorrow,
uh,
no.
But.
But the one thing you notice is that
there are probabilities.
But remember,
I mean the reason Kennedy's arms went up
like this when he was shot,
it was because it hit a kind of a nerve
cell.
In other words,
things happen when you start striking
nerves and,
or unpredictable or it could have hit
him in the neck.
What did hit him in the neck or behind
the shoulder.
But,
but that caused the arms to Jasper.
Watch this real quick.
Here's the seat.
When you see it,
it,
it's like an exit wound to me.
It kind of sprays for he his bow,
his head goes,
but nowhere to the left.
But that could easily have been because
of the,
you know,
just the nerve reaction like that.
So that's what I'm saying is that it's,
although it does go back into the left
leg,
it,
I know,
but that's predictable.
There's,
there's,
um,
there's executions of a Chinese
nationalists killing Chinese communist
and you watch them and they'll do it
over and over and over again.
And most of the time things go the way
you think they should.
And sometimes they don't know.
Bodies are weird.
There's a delay when it goes back into
the left,
there's a delay that almost
seems to indicate that maybe it was,
um,
a nerve reaction.
We'll see that the arm is going up
because the bullet goes,
but watch the bullet hits,
can't believe or watched it.
So again,
the bullet hits and then there's this
back into the left.
That could be from the impact of the gun
to it.
Remember the car is also moving,
which is making you,
you know,
it's,
it's hard to tell.
And then here's another thing to take
into consideration.
It's entirely possible that he was hit
with two bullets in the head at the same
time.
That is a possibility.
I'm not going to deny it.
And I'm also going to say the reason
that it would be interesting to know the
answer.
I mean,
if somebody could come down from the
extra terrestrials to tell,
you know,
this is what really is,
that it would tell you a lot about
subsequent history,
right?
Um,
in that sense,
the problem with it though is if you buy
into the conspiracy theory as it's
normally told,
then that basically takes you down this
road that,
okay,
there was a coo,
the president was killed by the
government,
and then that all subsequent history
from that point on then takes a,
you know,
like,
they say with time travel,
you change something and you go off on a
totally different course.
All history goes on a totally different
course if that's what really happened.
In other words,
everything must be looked through a
different lens.
If I was to believe as I used to,
that that was done by the government,
then my whole common sense show would be
totally different.
But it doesn't mean don't.
You have to look at everything from a
different lens when you find something
like operation northwoods,
when you find the northwoods documents,
you see that it's signed by the Joint
Chiefs of staff that this was a real
plan.
They were thinking about implementing
and Kennedy put the boycott on it.
Well,
what they did,
some of this,
I mean operation northwoods is not that
far from things they did in other
places.
Um,
you know,
and wasn't Cheney,
I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but we're trying to do something about
that with Iran.
Wasn't there a similar thing that was on
the table for a false flag to try to get
us into Iran before the end of the Bush
administration?
Was there something that was being
reported?
Maybe that was on infowars.com.
I don't remember that.
Can you find that?
See if you can find that.
But false flag.
I ran a Rumsfeld or Cheney,
I don't remember who it was.
The problem that all those people have
is if they think.
I always try to give people the benefit
of the doubt and say,
if you came to me with secret
information and says blah,
blah,
the country needs to do this now and you
say to yourself,
but I could never get the American
people to go along with that.
So if they knew what I knew they would,
but they won't.
So because of that,
I'm going,
you know,
see,
you start to try to figure out,
instead of just automatically going to
conspiracy,
right?
You Go,
okay,
could there be a logical reason that I
would accept and understand that would
explain the same sequence of events?
But I always try to do that.
Now.
I say that as somebody who clearly knows
the CIA's record,
I mean that's been one of my interests
forever.
The stuff that they do,
I can't think of any natural limitations
on.
I can't think of anything with the CIA
would have said no,
I wouldn't do that if the president
wanted us to.
I don't think many people know this,
but you know,
in the Nixon administration there was
talk about killing Jack Anderson,
the investigative reporter,
and it was g dot Gordon Liddy who had
offered to run him down with a car.
So when you talk about that and there
are people around the president who are
willing to consider the option will then
I have to say,
you know,
Dan,
you have to open up your mind to the
possibility that these things can
happen.
And as I said,
my opinion for years was that it did.
So I'm so,
I'm not not open to the idea to propose
this,
to provoke war.
Cheney considered proposal to dress up
navy seals as Iranians and shooted them.
It's a real source of this.
Got To be careful.
What is it after he knows how to Seymour
Hersh,
he's,
you know,
Seymour's getting a Pulitzer prize
winning journalist for the New York,
New York Seymour.
Seymour Hersh is the one who broke
things like,
I think he broke me.
Eli massacre and things like that.
As I said earlier though,
Cheney is really a nefarious character
in terms of,
you know,
if you weigh him next to the 19 fifties,
the,
the idea of fair play and the American
way.
He didn't believe any of that stuff.
It's a doggy dog world and whatever you
and I considered an American values is
marketing and you reacted to.
I mean it's all about,
you know,
it's,
it's real politic as they can.
Right?
It's such a weird character because he's
almost biblical.
Like when he had that heart implant and
his body wasn't giving off a pulse
anymore and the heart was just,
this artificial heart was just circling
the blood,
like he literally was alive without a
pulse.
How do you listen to the Bible anymore?
The WHO listens to him.
I mean Fox News people.
Ugh.
What is weird?
Why?
While he wants to do it,
like why wouldn't you want to fade back?
He still wants to influence the process.
Are you talking about the guy with the
Rolodex?
Right.
He must clearly enjoy it.
Shots and people in his Rolodex.
I bet bird seed wasn't incidentally
shuttered.
Shot face.
I used to do a joke about it.
That's how you know you were gangster.
You shoot your friend in the face and
your friend apologizes.
That's right.
That guy got on TV.
He's like,
I looked like a bird.
So sorry.
I was drunk.
He was totally sober.
That's right.
Listen,
Dan,
we just did three fucking hours.
We did.
I thought we were just getting started.
We just did three hours was every time
we do you know what you're going to hear
afterwards,
right?
We didn't talk about any history unless
the JF Kennedy assassination.
Sounds like it's a history.
That's certainly true.
We talked about a lot of good shit.
Now,
the three hours of the.
Anytime you want to do it again,
man,
we'll do another three.
Thank you buddy.
You're always so good to appreciate your
brother.
Your.
Your podcast is one of my favorite
things in all of audio recorded history.
I just want to thank you for it.
Thank you for introducing me to the cons
because it wasn't for that.
I would never have been Mongo obsessed
and thanks just for being awesome,
man.
I appreciate it.
Thank you for having me.
Thanks everybody.
We'll see you Saturday fight companion
who see that?
I know I'm going get.